public hearing on
12:41 okay great um and uh here
from uh not the
sponsor good morning Mr chairman for the
record representative Cole House Bill
1241 this bill revises the regulation
and lure of money transmitters by the
banking Department this is bills
requested by the banking department so
what we're going to do today is we're
going to call the banking heads and let
them discuss the bill since they know
what they're talking about in much
greater detail than we do
perfect okay
okay so
um you guys at some point need yeah if
you have a feel pink cards
great
okay all right so we have uh Bob
lber from the banking
department and good morning good morning
um for the record yes my name is B
berdie uh Deputy general counsel for the
New Hampshire banking Department I'm
joined by caki The General Counsel um
we're here as was said uh in support or
on behalf of the department in support
of HB um
1241 um just to give you a little
background this bill is really a
continuation of uh an effort last year
in HB
522 um which was adopted and went into
effect over the summer that bill if you
may recall adopted nine exemptions from
What's called the model money
transmission modernization act
um and this bill
1241 finishes the adoption by pulling in
the rest of that mtma into RSA 399 G
um I don't want to take up too much of
the committee's time by going into
specifics it is a long bill it's a
replace and uh reenact
bill but I will just say uh to note that
there are a couple things that don't
change um the exemptions from last year
don't change that includes the crypto
exemption that has come up frequently in
discussions here this year and last year
um
and uh yeah with that I I guess I'm open
to any questions the committee has at
this point
we have questions from committee
members okay representative
Herbert uh what's the relationship with
this legislation and
crypto uh that's a good question thank
you for asking I the relationship in so
far as it relates to
crypto
it's it's tangential in some respects
because in many instances crypto firms
are not subject to uh registration under
the money transmission act um the money
transmission act the registration Act
only applies to firms that that transmit
Fiat uh so if there is a company that
operates in both spheres crypto and Fiat
they would have to be registered with
the department but the jurisdiction of
the department only extends to certain
subsets
of the Transmissions that they
undertake for the question M inquire um
so as of this point in time there hasn't
been uh anyone who has tried to register
uh as a money transfer uh service crypto
in other
words uh I don't know the exact number I
can tell you I I think I can say pretty
certainly that we have some entities
that are registered that do operate with
crypto but we do not we have no
jurisdiction over those particular
transactions so we don't regulate it in
other words right now um any crypto
transaction if somebody has a problem
with it you would be calling the
Attorney General's office you would you
be uh using it it's a consumer
protection issue it would not have
anything to do with the banking
Department
that's right unless and until Fiat um
unless Fiat is being transmitted in
which case they may fall under the
jurisdiction of the banking
Department okay a lot of questions but
that's be okay so yeah so this has been
right from the get-go Chris that that
we've always have basically treated that
crypto if remember the beanie
baby remember the when we used to call
crypto beating babies U no not really
but okay but that they were a commodity
crypto is a commodity it's not it's not
money it's not Fiat yeah okay so there
is no regulation we don't have anything
to do with it when it comes to the
banking
Department okay but you have somebody
who registers who is registered well if
a company does both yeah then they would
have to register right so why don't you
describe a typical company who what kind
of companies are we talking about about
here for the most part money
transmission we're talking about I mean
to use a classic example would be the
Western Unions of the world or literally
sending money Fiat money from one
location to another
um and there's been some I think
questions at the at the federal level on
how that interplays with the crypto uh
firms and the fintech firms and that's
what this legislation I think is
designed to sort of clarify or start to
clarify
actually I found that U I tried to use
Western Union once for my daughter and
it didn't work out while I flunk the
tests that they were asking and and then
then someone said well why don't you
just go down to a Walmart and it turns
out all you have to do is find another
Walmart and they transfer the money
right over for you piece of cake that's
another example okay but again it's
transferring
money and and then to the somebody else
who's then getting the money
money is Fiat cash going both ways um
are are you familiar with the fact that
uh the uh these payroll companies check
companies have a problem with this
legislation are you guys aware of this
uh I'm not aware uh as far as I know
everyone who's seen that well the
department hasn't received any sort of
negative feedback on the really I'm
shocked Peter you haven't talked to the
banking Department about
this
okay well then I might have to ask you
back after you hear from these folks who
have an issue otherwise representative
Ammon has a question I do I'm trying
to thank you for your testimonies I I
missed the beginning of it so I
apologize for that uh I had a question
about the definition of monetary value
it seems to have changed since the
previous uh iteration of
this
and I'll tell you specifically in a
second here I'm waiting for my internet
to boot
sure like
to
so where is that in the bill it's in the
definitional section oh definitions okay
yeah
so did you say monetary value yeah
there's a definition of monetary value
means a medium exchange whether or not
redeemable in
money yeah so the old definition said uh
medium exchange medium exchange whether
or not redeemable in currency and and
includes convertible virtual currency
and so that that latter part was
dropped in money period because
it's so when it's referred to in the
statute what do it referred to as the
existing statute the definition of
monetary
value I'll read the whole definition
it's monetary value means a medium of
exchange whether or not redeemable in
currency and includes convertible
virtual
currency and the D the new definition
says it's a medium of exchange whether
or not redeemable in money okay so
that's a definition so in the statute
does it talk about what what's I I don't
know the the ramifications of that but I
just thought I'd asked the question so
so yeah so we don't know where do we
where do we I guess I have to if I had
my computer yeah to do a fine search all
right when they type in monetary value
and maybe we can deal with this in
subcommittee but just wanted to
definitely we could
right that's a um thank you for the
question I I don't want to speak out of
turn without having a chance to look
through it again myself but I wonder the
model act has a um an optional article
specifically on on cryptocurrency that
we did not include in this bill and I
wonder if that might be a hold over of
um that specific article um that just
wasn't changed but again I would have to
look through a little bit more closely
maybe in subcommittee to figure that out
can I just follow for the question being
I guess this is what you believe at this
point but uh what you believe New
Hampshire has had an advantage in this
area for since 2017 and my concern is
that we don't want to give up that
advantage and go back backwards so if we
could just be careful about yep I
understand
okay okay so we will we'll address that
in the subcommittee when this okay don't
go far thank
you all right so Peter who did you want
to go first here myself Rob
okay
oh yeah come
after
set yeah go uh thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
Peter bragon uh senior policy adviser
with predy strategies here representing
the independent payroll providers
Association also joined today with Robin
in brogno from the payroll group uh
we're two industry Association
representing the independent uh smaller
payroll processing uh companies um I'm
here as the uh pretty face not knowing
much about anything which I'm not
probably succeeding at very well at all
myself uh but Robin knows all about the
industry and specifically we would
request to be uh have payroll processors
uh excluded uh amongst the list of those
exclusions that are in the bill but
Robin can speak more to the the
issue okay good morning good morning I'm
here on behalf of both the payroll group
and the independent uh payrolls
providers
Association uh collectively our groups
represent over 300 Peril processors
across the United States several uh of
which are here with us today um and we
have several members here in New
Hampshire our members consist of small
and mediumsized Regional Peril companies
and together um we
represent um registered agents for the
IRS um in total in total with the IRS
there are over 28,000 reporting agents
that are
registered as payroll uh as payroll
reporting agents in the state of New
Hampshire there are 460 firms that are
listed under the niic Cs code AS
accountants tax preparers bookkeepers
and Payroll Services what's interesting
is that 90% of those firms have less
than 20
employees small payroll companies
provide an essential service to New
Hampshire businesses in addition to
payroll processing and tax filing
Services many of those act as business
advisors to those small compan
ianes with respects to wage and hour
laws providing um advice and Counsel on
things like sick leave administering
your new family medical leave during
times of covid with the payroll uh
protection act and preparing for to get
the loans and how to fill out the
paperwork how to find the payroll
reports that were needed to complete
their filing applications for the banks
many of those Regional Banks um were
requesting a lot of information from
those uh employers that are in your
state those Regional payroll processors
worked weekends and nights with those
small businesses holidays Easter Sunday
they were working with your uh your
small employers throughout the state to
provide them with the education that
they need needed to be able to
understand the law so that they could
get those
loans they also worked with them for all
of the covid um exemptions that they
needed to get covid sick leave pay for
their
employees so when we were working till 8
9:00 at night to help those
employers the companies that we call Big
Red and big blue were closing their
doors at 5:00 to go home and those large
corporations may be the only ones that
are left to be able to serve the
Employers in New Hampshire if this bill
continues to pass because the regional
payroll companies will not be able to
afford to stay in
business there are two major reasons for
this 1241
specifically act as agents
of
employers we will have extreme
difficulty in maintaining the
compliance that is due to the
nature that's required of this
act and required within this act of our
Peril companies the cost of compliance
will put many of the small Regional
Peril providers out of
business Peril processors by Nature
of what we
do act as agents of the
employers by the
IRS there's a form that I've included in
the packets that have just been put out
to you called an
8655 that IRS form designates us as an
agent of the
employer that
form allows us to pay taxes on behalf of
the employers both in this state and all
states
we encourage employers to look behind us
an employer can look at their taxes
being paid on a weekly daily monthly
anytime they like to make sure that
those taxes are being paid on it on
their
behalf without a Peril
processor those Services can be made by
an employer in many cases 10 years ago
15 years ago without a regional payroll
processor
because many companies don't like using
big blue and big red they did try to do
it on their own and in many times
employers fell behind paying their taxes
because when they had to make a choice
between paying a tax perhaps putting a
new piece of equipment on the
floor they chose the
ladder we make sure that they take the
time to pay their
taxes
in
addition to paying taxes and acting as
an agent you should know that the bill
requires us to
ensure that we are complying in full
with that act which may mean that if an
employer has an employee in another
state so if that
employer opens up a branch in your state
and we are working for an employer out
of
state we may be out of compliance
immediately so if we're working for an
employer in
Massachusetts and they hire someone in
New
Hampshire we have to tell that employer
we can no longer work for
them or we're out of
compliance we are put in a position
where it's
untenable so if we unless we
immediately comply by proactively
registering in your state for out of
state Peril processors it's impossible
for us to
comply with this
act the issue presents a serious concern
for us and the csbs model law
specifically names a Peril processor as
a money transmitter you all just talk
talked about
cryptocurrency we have where is that in
the Bild you know so where thank you I
can answer that sorry to cut you off but
it help on page uh three of the bill
line uh 26 and
27 um under the definition of money
transmission uh the end of line 26 says
the term includes payroll processing
Services okay great sorry for my thank
you
so unless we register proactively we're
put in a position where we either have
to terminate a client or we choose not
to pay an
employee neither of those are acceptable
options for
us another major concern for us is the
unsurmountable cost of compliance I
provided with uh to you a second exhibit
exhibit B
in exhibit B it shows you the
costs for apparel
processor for a CPA firm and for a
bookkeeper because we all fall into the
same
category it's the exhibit that's in
blue those costs show the bonding
costs the potential cost to register not
again just in your state because the
csbs model legislation is being
presented in many states and
again with covid and the explosion of
the remote
workers you could have an
employer that's not just having
employees here in New Hampshire but
could have an employee working for a
company in New Hampshire but they have
an employee working in Massachusetts or
potentially working in
Vermont or working in another state and
it's not clear at all in the model
legislation who needs to be
covered so if we have to register in
multiple States because that company has
employees in multiple States we have to
register in all of those States and be
bonded in all of those states and
bonding is not consistent in all of
those States
either so that study in exhibit B shows
what those potential costs are and I
think it's fairly easy to see that for a
small Peril
processor either we would have to
significantly increase our costs or
close our doors for these reasons we
request that New Hampshire reconsider an
exemption for agency payroll processors
similar to the states of California Ohio
North Carolina Washington and most
recently
Iowa please know in closing and you'll
hear this from some of my associates
that are right here in New
Hampshire that we are required to
provide sock audits to the banks that
provide us with the kinds of services
that we provide our banks which is in
sending our a files we required to
provide Notch
audits we underwrite in most cases for
our banks our clients making sure that
they too are
viable we have to provide personal
financial statements to those Banks we
do ofac reviews on those clients as
well
so we do a lot to ensure as well the
safety of what we
do and we do provide a consultative
service to those clients that we provide
services to we're asking you to take
that all into consideration as
well thank you and I'd be happy to
answer any
questions and if I could add um I passed
out a um copy of a report from the state
of New York in uh 2022 there was similar
legislation in New York to require the
uh licensure registration processing
Services um after we testify there's a
couple local companies that will testify
and also point out that you know when we
think payroll processing companies we
think of the the big the big companies
out there the big National companies uh
we represent the regional companies but
a lot of small businesses use their
local bookkeeper to help them with their
payroll uh or the local CPA firm and uh
so this would have put all those costs
on them and and especially in the age of
remote workers where you can have
workers living all over the country uh
it presents an untenable situation but
happy to answer any questions uh how did
this happen how when when they were
building this model legislation where
were you
guys well I can tell you it wasn't us
that were sitting on the advisory
committee because if it was we wouldn't
be sitting here today so all this time
they were doing this and you were
unbeknownst to you guys that that this
was happening we we definitely came in
after the fact
okay okay and and we respectfully we are
the two largest um independent
associations representing our industry
right it just it's just unbelievable how
is how it's in here as not you know not
even worry about the exemption but it's
how they they went out of their way to
put you in here and yet nobody called
you up and nobody said oh by the way
there's my my understanding was there
was a presentation made at some point
when model legislation was being
developed um and the response back was
oh that's an interesting concept we'll
have to look into that but in the
meantime we want to get our legislation
through but as I indicated uh a number
of states that have seen this model
legislation have uh recognized the uh
the issues here
okay okay we do have questions represent
spear I just want to make sure I
understand this in the previous version
one that this is updating
uh you folks were not in that bill right
and that's and the whole reason is now
that you're folded into
it thank you for the question
representative my understanding is the
uh current statute RSA is it 399 G I
think uh does not uh include payroll
processors the uh legislation before you
specifically includes payroll processors
got that that's what reac I I think U I
think that my question was just answered
thank you
okay uh any other questions from the
committee me representa Ammon uh unless
I missed it thank you Mr chair thank you
for uh taking my question uh what's the
fix for your issue is it just to exclude
money transmitters is that yes thank you
for the question remove it right you got
to you got to do two things yeah we
specifically two things remove the
language in that includes it and uh also
we request a specific exclusion so that
there's no uh question and future uh
departments may try to interpret things
differently and we can provide samples
of language from the other states that
have done
this okay so here's The $64,000 Question
who
regulates this
industry so um that's a a good question
and I know that represent hunt in my
prior conversations with you uh
referenced an incident that happened in
uh prior to 2000 I think prior to the
pandemic um a company uh a pay
Processing Company in New York uh was
misbehaving and caused a problem which
affected the I think it's the Hometown
Diner in constituent lost $20,000 yeah
so uh and one of the issues there was so
the um they went to send the money
unemployment taxes and he said other
than occasional little clerical errors
there have not been any issues with with
that so um I think it's it's regulated
to the point by the IRS uh some of the
banking trade groups that uh regulate
you know how we can interact with them
um as well as other various trade
associations I don't know how I did with
that if I could just add to that um the
banks do require uh those of us who send
files through the banks an a notcha
audit we are required to do those
annually by the end of December each
year um so that and in New York States
uh findings you'll see that they felt
that that was uh remediation for that
issue and in those audits it uh
purposefully reviews um any reversals to
Consumer accounts specifically okay did
you just say that state that one more
time for me because who is doing the
auditing um so we have to have an
outside auditor review um all
transactions uh annually our our files
are reviewed to determine if there are
any reversals made um and causation so
who's required this who made this
requirement right it's called a nacha
audit the notcha audit and in those
notcha audits they were they look for
specifically that's one of the things
that they look for so you're registered
with no we're required to provide it if
we but how do they know you exist how
what because we pass Bank files right so
if you are putting a file into the
banking system okay okay you are
required so this is anybody who puts a
bank file your bank must require you to
provide it to the bank so we can't
provide our we can't have a bank
relationship you know there's certain
things that we have to provide our bank
every year um we actually have to
provide our bank with things four times
a year but one of the things annually
that we have to provide them with is a
notch audit if we don't provide it we
lose our ability to send nacha files
that be up to the bank to it's not up to
them it's required by right but I'm
saying if you don't send it they will
turn us off then they would say they
would notify the bank that the bank
notifies us you're off so the bank so
you are required to give this audit to
the bank correct so if I think in terms
of my happy homeowner or happy business
I have QuickBooks and QuickBooks I can
transfer uh Bank check payments and I'm
doing that electronically so because I
do that they can shut me off from being
able to do that if I don't give them an
audit you wouldn't fall under this
because you're not a third- party sender
we fall under that as a third-party
sender so our relationship with the bank
requires us to so your your connection
to the bank would not be my federal ID
number it would be your federal ID
number so that's how the bank knows that
who you are and what's the nature of
your business and then they're the ones
who are requiring that audit correct
okay thank you thank you all right
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair what is
nacha it's the National Association of
Clearing Houses so it's where all
electronic transactions go um for the
Federal
Reserve um it's what it it's how
electronic transactions get moved to
make a direct deposit
happen question sure thank you uh so
that's a Trader Association doesn't that
amount to the company's regulating
themselves it's it's not a trade or it's
part of the Federal
Reserve thank
you
yeah
um so I already went and had a little
conversation with them okay and um they
will be prepared uh theoretically um the
bank commissioner is not here today so
so they can't they can't tell them you
know make a decision at this point but
uh what we will have is when we have the
subcommittee um we will hope that we'll
have the language the amendment proper
Amendment unless the banking Department
can have a different opinion they can
offer it up at the subcommittee but but
at this point my expectation is that
we'll have an amendment drawn to take
care of this
problem with that thank you uh thank you
very
much okay so the other two I know you
came here uh um so and and you obviously
want to speak so i t with Josh
Robinson and all I could say is don't
repeat anything we haven't said and I
think we we certainly get the problem
and we certainly want to fix it for you
absolutely um and thank you for taking a
few minutes to hear me um I will uh just
uh my testimony is specifically in
regards to my company um and the impact
of the legislation I'll be quick it
sounds like um uh we're we're moving uh
you know in a uh a direction kind of in
alignment here so um so I'm Josh
Robinson I'm the president and second
generation owner of Checkmate payroll
service serves uh were based in
conquered um I'm a lifelong New
Hampshire resident and my family we
moved from Bo to hopkington in
2021 um I uh I currently serve on the
greater conquered Chamber of Commerce
but I am here uh uh to provide testimony
as a citizen of the state and owner of a
payroll Processing Company and you know
in no other um uh you know not speaking
in any other voice here um our company
is 100% New Hampshire based we employ
about 20 uh well-compensated
professionals primarily in technology
focused roles our client base is
comprised of hundreds of employers from
your neighborhood auto repair shops
convenience stores Medical Professional
practices to larger high-tech
manufacturing operations and the
occasional startup with a new business
model that quickly grows and expands
into a multi-state employer with complex
tax reporting needs and I think one of
the best ways to kind of just reiterate
like demonstrate what Robin was saying
as far as the impact on our business and
why you know these concerns about about
Audits and you know regulation um well
it might be somewhat alleviated is just
to give you a little company history my
father started the company in 1987 as an
offsh or rather in '94 as an offshoot to
his CPA firm which he had started in
1987 um and so we originally had seven
clients that we processed payroll for
and over a number of years uh without
any or you know actual real sales effort
um we organically grew uh to a point
where when I bought the company we were
uh a little over a million and a half in
annual revenue servicing about 350
customers uh currently we are um more
than double that I've owned the company
since uh
2013 um and most of our customers are
New Hampshire based employers as
Checkmate grew we evolved our company
our customers evolved they demanded new
things of us such as sock Audits and you
know uh we then decided that we needed
to have you know as our a numbers grew
that we needed to have more control over
the electronic transactions of our
customers um and so we established
Direct Banking relationships and now we
have annual a audits that were subject
to and sock audits that require as well
in addition we have our own internal um
requirements of ourselves that compel us
to you know reconcile our bank accounts
on a daily basis and do a number of
other things like business continuity
testing um that aren't you know demanded
through regulation but are demanded
because any reasonable business owner
who would rely on us to manage their
number one operating expense would you
know want to know that these things are
in place so the the basic gist of this
as Robin said uh is the the burden of
this regulation is so vast on a company
like mine we would need to have a
dedicated employee um just to make sure
that we are routinely ongoing compliant
with all of the rules and regulations
that are laid out in this bill we would
need to pay an additional 30 to 50K a
year um just to get audited uh company
financials on top of all of these other
things that we already do and it's just
as as as Robin was indicating New
Hampshire is one of many states that are
considering similar legislation it is
the broader scale of this that really is
the thing that that that is puts us all
at risk of shutting down our businesses
but any one state that does this um you
know makes that a more real and present
danger for all of us so I'm happy to
take any questions that you might
have I thank you very much for your
testimony and appreciate uh the success
your business has here in New Hampshire
thank you sure you pay a lot of business
profits tax we
do okay Matt Matt
gastas from
javanes
good
morning
morning so it's probably very uh kind of
repetitive here but um chairman hunt
distinguished committee members and
guests my name is Matthew gatsis I'm
here today with my brother-in-law Dan
Casey we are here representing
trivantis triantis is a family-owned
local payroll company owned by my father
Michael gatsis trivantis has been pay
providing payroll services for the last
21 years in New Hampshire and two New
Hampshire based companies trivantis has
24 employees all who reside in New
Hampshire our only office is in located
in downtown Manchester New Hampshire the
average siiz client we provide payroll
services for has 14
employees as you can see we are small
business providing a crucial service to
other small small businesses in New
Hampshire so they can control
concentrate on their Core
Business my father and uncle Ted gatas
started staffing network
1989 this was a professional employee
organization that provided Payroll
Services as you can see our family has
been in the payroll business in New
Hampshire for 35 years at this time I
would like to speak about the house bill
1241 which you have before your
committee it is our professional opinion
that this bill as written will create a
hardship and burden on companies like
ours to continue servicing our clients
and their payroll needs local
accountants bookkeepers and payroll
companies will find these rules raise
their cost to the point where they will
have no will have to consider other
options this reill this bill requires
triantis to provide audited
financials we would need to hire an
outside accounting firm to Prov provide
this service for us this would be
extremely costly some of the smaller
payroll companies will have a difficult
obtaining these statements also to
obtain assurity bond will only add
additional cost which will have to be
passed to our small business clients
doing business with us New Hampshire has
always provide prided itself as a state
which is friendly to small business and
supports local business for these
reasons and more we are requesting that
payroll providers be excluded for this
bill
perfect thank you very much for your
testimony thank you having uh no more
cards we'll close the public
hearing yes this bill will go to a
subcommittee and will be
addressed
okay
all right ready for the next
one Yes actually is the clerk ready yes
she's ready
all right thank you Mr chair members of
the
committee uh sticking to house tradition
I'm introducing this
bill uh House Bill
1559 uh repealing the chapter relative
to cash dispensing
machines and it's fortunately very
simple bill it's repealing RSA 399 F
relative to cash dispensing machines the
entire RSA is
repealed and I I won't take questions
because I think the banking Department
might be coming behind me so thank
you right thank
you nothing like a bill that has my name
on it that says repeal a
statute okay Seth saraki correct good
morning chairman hunt members of the
committee my name is Seth Zaraki I'm the
general counsel at the New Hampshire
banking department and I'm here speaking
on behalf of the department uh HB 1559
will repeal RSA 399 F in its entirety
this is the chapter relative to the
registration of non-bank cash dispensing
machines in New Hampshire um so cash
dispensing machines are electronic
devices that allow consumers to debit
their account in exchange for dispensing
cash um they essentially look like ATMs
but the difference is Cash dispensing
machines are operated by businesses
other than Banks or credit unions and
are only capable of dispensing cash as
opposed to conducting other transactions
like
deposits uh the New Hampshire banking
Department currently maintains a
registry of non-bank cash dispensing
machines um but we support the repeal of
this chapter for the following reasons
first uh the repeal will result in the
elimination of the Department's registry
and the administrative burdens
associated with maintaining it under
current law the department is permitted
to collect Annual fees of only $50 for
new registrations and $5 for renewals
the Department's experience is that the
staff time and administrative costs
associated with maintaining that
registry considerably ex exceed any
value in having that registry in short
the evidence that we have shows that
it's just not worth it um furthermore
RSA currently it contains no enforcement
Provisions so if there were a consumer
issue with a cash dispensing machine the
department has limited statutory
authority to take any meaningful action
moreover uh the Department's records
reflect that it has received only one
Consumer complaint relating to a cash
dispensing machine during the time that
it's maintained uh this registry
um because of the confidentiality
protections associated with consumer
complaints I'm limited in what I can
disclose about that but um that one
complaint had to be resolved uh through
the customer's Bank rather than the
operator this the cash dispensing
machine anyway um following the repeal
of the statute any consumer protection
issues relating to cash cash dispensing
machines will be will remain or will be
subject to the provisions of uh the
consumer protection act RSA
358a so in some consumer uh we believe
the repeal is appropriate at the banking
Department um consumer protections under
the consumer protection act will M uh M
be intact um and it will eliminate the
unnecessary registration and
administrative burdens both for business
and for state government with that I'd
be happy to answer any
questions okay representative Speer I I
I read this statute and uh as it exists
right now and
and correct me if I'm wrong I I'm pretty
sure in like in the third line it said
that it included
ATMs does this mean that ATMs are not
regulated anymore and they can just do
whatever they want no yes I appreciate
the question representative um now ATMs
um I'm well first I'm not sure what
provision you may be referring to in in
current law um so the definition in
current law of a cash dispensing machine
is an electron device that operating in
conjunction with a processor Network
allows a consumer to debit an account in
exchange for dispensing cash um ATMs um
those are defined yeah uh ATMs are are
defined in another section of the
banking laws in RSA 383b those will
continue to be un regulated um under our
authority to regulate Banks and Credit
Unions right so these are these are the
ones you see inside grocery stor
or certain businesses who want to be
cash only they have have them there so
representative melier thank you chairman
is there any limit to how much one of
these U machines can charge for
dispensing
cash there
is no limit so long as it's dis there
disclosed um on a signed post posted on
the cash dispensing machine that's in
current law 399 F4 I would say that um
if if hypothetically there was some
excessive fee Associated on you know on
the machine that could F be that could
be a violation of like an unfair and
deceptive practice under under current
law under 3858
a right so let's make sure we understand
that one okay so now because the banking
department is no longer going to
register these that means if you have
have a complaint you would actually go
to the consumer protection act the AG's
office and there's an unfair trade
practice okay so that that is much like
what we did with crypto we took it away
from the banking any registration the
bank department has any connection to it
so now if there's a problem it's Now
does not fall under their jurisdiction
it falls under the Attorney General's
office as a consumer protection act
representative Gibs thanks Mr chair uh
just for clarity you mentioned um uh
cash dispensing machines inside Grocery
Stores um that would uh now be covered
under the consumer protection act uh and
not covered by the banking department
but just for an example um uh about a
mile from here there's a Market Basket
grocery store on store Street and inside
that grocery store is a Citizens Bank
ATM M am I correct that that Citizens
Bank ATM would still be regulated by the
banking
department so yeah appreciate the
question representative um since well
Citizens Bank is a federally Chartered
bank so that would be regulated by a
Federal Banking regulator however um for
example if there were a uh an ATM in you
know on a street corner or in a grocery
store that is run by a a bank or a
credit union that is State Charter that
is regulated by the New Hampshire
banking Department that would continue
to remain under our uh jurisdiction and
Regulatory Authority thank you thank you
okay so we all know the difference
between an ATM and a cash dispensing
machine uh I I would have to say I first
kind of paid attention to years ago we
had this bill and on the one that got it
lowered to $5 for the renewal but uh
then I was uh I did get a notice from my
bank that said uh that they would um
anytime I use an ATM let's say we
foreign an ATM that was not my bank um
they actually reimbursed me for the
fee so that's why you always want to go
to an a a real ATM a real Bank rather
than than one of these cash dispensing
machines and with that thank you very
much thank
you okay I have no other cards interest
on
1559 so I will close the public hearing
1559 okay I don't see representative
Spain in the room so maybe I'll need to
go find
him oh actually not even not even time
yet how do we catch up oh that's great
all right
perfect
all right uh representative Spain
will'll come up and introduce his
bill good morning representative Spain
thank you Mr chair good morning and
members of the
committee um I'm bringing this bill to
you in an attempt to try to
preliminarily address a situation that's
becoming more and more of an issue as
technological advances are being made
with Vehicle Manufacturer more and more
vehicles uh you've probably heard of the
right to repair effort that's been going
on in many states more and more
manufacturers have proprietary
technological information that they
don't want to release because it's
patented technology and the legality of
forcing a company to disclose that
information when it's patented
technology is kind of
nebulous and so some states have gone
the route of forcing manufacturers to
disclose uh proprietary systems of the
vehicle to third party
garages many if not all of those have
ended up in lawsuits and litigation that
may not yet even be settled and so I
decided I would like to try to
preliminarily start to address this
problem by at least making sure that a
buyer is able to beware as we've heard
many times buyer
beware so all this bill is trying to do
is ask that when a manufacturer is
producing a vehicle that has proprietary
systems in it that can only be repaired
at the dealership
you know uh that they can't take it to
their local garage to have repairs done
if they buy it that it's on the window
sticker with all the other information
that's disclosed upon far as mileage
goes and all those other things the
warranty the mileage and all that it
should also tell them hey by the way if
you buy this you might have to go to the
dealership to have certain parts of the
vehicle repaired because we don't
disclose that proprietary information to
your local dealer or your local
garage um I have also passed around or
asked uh representative Pusa to pass
around an amendment that I had drafted
because shortly after the bill was
drafted I was contacted by a motorcycle
group that informed me hey by the way
this applies to motorcycles and we don't
have a passenger side window to stick a
sticker on and I said Jo I didn't even
intend it to cover those so the
amendment simply strikes motorcycles
from the vehicles that would require
that you let the buyer know that they
might have to pay $300 an hour at the uh
for for service at a dealership instead
of
60 $70 an hour down the
street um I am going to also say that
the I've been in discussion with the
chair of transportation and he is very
keen on potentially amending this to add
more uh stuff to it so he may be in
contact with your subcommittee that does
do work on this and um I'm going to find
out if he PL I I don't see him here
today so I guess he's not speaking on it
today but he did have an opinion that
there was more that could be done with
some issues that he had and being that
I'm not in transportation I don't know
the technicality of what it was he was
looking
at and I'm open for any questions if
anybody has
any you do represent Speer has a
question I'm not going to go through my
uh user manual tirade but do you mean
when you say on the window sticker are
you talking about that big thing that
goes on the front window you know when
you buy a or on a side window when you
buy a car that L all that you don't mean
a permanent little tiny sticker no no no
just that W that sales sticker oh okay
thank you
yep and it doesn't have I had the
question before that does it have to
list all the components that are
proprietary I said no this the way the
Bill's written it just has to say this
vehicle has proprietary repair
information in it representative mclair
uh thank you what's to stop being a
automobile manufacturer from just
declaring everything as proprietary I
mean I I could is anybody going to
regulate this at all I I would say no
but it would probably behoove a
manufacturer to to say that it's not
proprietary so that somebody's more
likely to buy it because I know I for
one like to do a lot of the repairs
myself on my Toyotas and I also uh have
a local shop I go to and if I was going
to go buy a new Toyota and um I had two
choices to choose from I'd pick the one
that I don't have to worry about going
to the dealership every time I bring it
in right because this is just generic
one little sentence you're adding to the
sticker on side of your car and um um
the Auto Dealers Association um D met
did call me and said that he was unable
to make it today but uh he said the
question he would pose to you is um of
all
the cars that are being
manufactured how what percentage of them
are going to be sold here in New
Hampshire and do you really think that a
manufacturer is going to put this on
every car that's sold just to comply
with New Hampshire law it'd be great if
they did the ink doesn't cost
anything so and if they set the set
their computer system up that prints all
those tags to automatically add it then
everybody else in the nation gets a
bonus question question well let me make
sure everybody anybody else because
you've already had a question uh so
representative Herbert has a question
then represent um what if any
impact on insurance that this have it
doesn't currently have an impact so I
don't think that disclosing it to the
consumer prior to purchase would have an
impact well if you say buyer beware
which makes sense to me you're saying
that if I have insurance on this car
beware because they're not going to pick
the bill
up I don't see how that has anything to
do with going into the shop to have your
repairs
done I mean if I bring my vehicle in to
get like for instance my Toyota had to
have a a throw arm on the transmission
replaced because the neutral switch was
faulty and for that my local shop
couldn't do it because they didn't have
the right tools it's totally different
from not being able to do it because
they won't disclose that information to
you and being forced to go there just so
that they can repair something that if
the information was provided to a local
garage they could fix um doesn't matter
where you go to get your vehicle fixed
uh Insurance isn't going to cover
something unless it's part of an
accident or or something like that as
far as I know I mean I don't have
insurance cover my transmission
issue well hopefully you won't for
question you may inquire I just I'm I'm
still not satisfied with the fact that
and you can have an accident or
something can happen and you would might
want to take it to your local uh you
know repair shop uh does that mean that
if I have an insurance policy on on my
car that says they'll pay
for accidental stuff and all that kind
of stuff does that mean that that might
my my local shop can't you know the
insurance is not going to pay for it
from my perspective from the times that
I've been reared or had insurance issues
when I make a claim with my insurance
company they ask me if I have a garage
of preference and if I do then they deal
with that garage and if if if they
support that garage and if they don't
like that garage they can offer me some
alternatives
but uh it's usually the insurance
company that gets involved prior to
taking it to a garage and if they have
their
Preference they make it known so if I
could just clarify what that further
question you may yes so if I understand
you correctly the insurance company will
on on a new car or a car with all the
gadgets will say you got to go over to
the
dealer sometimes they do that um I have
found that uh with the new electric
vehicles there's very little option then
to go to the dealer and as more and more
technology is being rolled into the
vehicles it's becoming more and more of
an issue where the local guy can't fix
things um and I as a consumer I want to
know before I buy a vehicle whether I
can fix it or take it to my local guy or
whether I'm going to be stuck going to
the dealership every time I need to have
something
done okay thank
you representative Ammon oh excuse me
representative spe here next actually I
think my question got answered
inadvertently by answering that question
representative Ammon thank you Mr chair
thank you representative Spain for
taking our questions um so I'm trying to
understand the bill uh reading it here
um there's a definition of used motor
vehicle uh that's used in the definition
of dealer and so uh my first question
would be does this apply to used
vehicles as well as new no it was only
meant to you to deal with new
vehicles but do yeah does say that and
see the definition of dealer includes
used
vehicles and it states that the
manufacturer has a responsibility right
and that's why it wasn't meant to deal
with used vehicles it was only supposed
to be applying to new vehicles and I
appreciate that catch uh as I said I
already have an amendment for taking the
motorcycle part out and uh I would
certainly welcome an amendment to take
the used vehicle portion out because
this was only meant to to deal with
brand new vehicles further question you
may inquire thank you um and then my my
SEC my my last question is uh at the end
I don't have line number but it's in the
Roman Nal 2 repair notice
required there's it talks
about uh so the the sticker legibly
States if the motor vehicle will require
any repairs that can only be made at a
dealership and lists any vehicle parts
that contain proprietary information so
um to me that means that there'll be a
list of parts and that which could be
quite extensive and then the definition
of proprietary information a lot of
those parts might have patents on them
that might be considered proprietary so
I get what you're saying um the it
should have said subsystems I suppose
because it should have basically had
what what were looking for them to list
is the computer module the
transmission emission system generically
parts of the vehicles not the actual
individual Parts on the vehicle that
would be
ridiculous um we just wanted people to
know that you know uh this vehicle has
proprietary uh systems that may need
repair in the transmission if if such
happens to it you have to go to the
dealership or in the computer module
that drive drives the engine um that way
you know that you know I only have these
couple of things I got to worry about
when you buy it you don't have to think
that every single part if you need new
tires you don't have to go to the dealer
we wanted to make it a little clearer to
the to the buyer what they're getting
into when they purchase the
vehicle well now you got me
confused because this is a generic
statement saying by the way there's some
something's in here that's proprietary
and we're not going to tell you what it
is because we're not required to under
statute we all required to tell you is
by the way there's something proprietary
right that was the intent and they they
put the subsystem section in there
um oh and list the vehicle parts that
and that wasn't that wasn't supposed to
be what it said so that's supposed to be
you want to amend that out also that
should also be amended out okay so after
we've done all these amendments and
going to bring it down to this very
simple concept very simple concept yes
so is there actually any new car being
produced
today that does not have something
proprietary in
it I can't answer that would you think
that maybe that could be
true well I can tell you that that the
guy that fixes my stuff down the road is
a Jeep uh guy but he's not a Jeep Jeep
dealer and he can fix even the brand new
jeeps he right right he can get the
parts for them but there's no
proprietary information that that uh he
has to that has to send the Jeep deal
for so what you just described is that
the issue here is me notwithstanding the
owner's manual which I don't think you
have to go beyond page two that will say
if you will have any problems with your
car for warranty repair please bring it
back to your dealer but that's warranty
repair I understand that but so we're
right out of the block the consumer is
being informed that yes you you you're
going to need to bring this to a dealer
but what you just pointed out is that
there are uh Ser other service centers
that can repair because they can get the
parts you know but they can't get the te
the information or technology for some
of the proprietary systems which is what
we're trying to inform the the buyer
about but then the caveat M tour here
how can you be buy or beware don't know
before you buy it I would venture to say
every consumer there is nobody who buys
a new car and doesn't already know that
there's something proprietary in that
new car with due respect Mr chairman we
wouldn't be having so many battles in
other states about forcing people to
release that proprietary information if
people weren't buying the vehicle and
then finding out later oh crap I've got
to go to the dealership and pay $300 an
hour for the labor every single time I'm
glad you brought that up Okay so we've
had that legislation in this
committee and we are acutely aware of
the issues in that sense that it was uh
a Massachusetts they actually did a
citizen referendum so they do that down
there and they actually passed a
referendum that they had to uh have the
proprietary information made to auto
dealers um since then there was a
negotiated compromise and then now you
know the dust is settled um but I just
heard because I the news and I think it
was public radio uh but I because that's
who I used into most but it was it was
the big issue was John Deer right and I
don't see yeah Henry's not here today
but uh John Deere and the issue was
these these half a million dollar
tractors and The Story Goes On about how
that uh he that it turns out what all it
needed to be part all it needed to be
fixed was a wire needed to be plugged
back in or something just the wire fell
out and he was upset that he had to call
the John Deere guy to come all the way
out to fix his his half a million dollar
thing to find out that it was just a
loose wire and that um and then
and he had to pay several hundred
dollars for travel time for that guy to
come out and do it so we are certainly
aware of this right to
repair concept and I certainly
appreciate that you certainly are are
trying to at least let consumers know
that it's going on but I would I am have
to admit you me frankly is that the
owner's manuals tells you so they might
just put in the manual put on your
screen there please read the owner
manuals for all our our
notices okay and think they're in
compliance with your statue which might
be a good thing thing to force you to
read your manual which you should have
read in the first place to find out that
there's proprietary I wouldn't think
that that was a bad thing at all um and
I appreciate your open mind on it and
the fact that I'm just trying to at
least get the consumers to have some
level of awareness before they purchase
fair enough okay now representative
spe one of the proprietary things with
an automobile is the um repair codes and
the uh the codes that indicate what what
the proc problems are and they're very
detailed and they usually require a
little device to interpret those codes
to download codes and to and to
interpret those codes a lot of these
repair places that
are less
than I don't know efficient don't have
those things and so to repair something
is is a black box to them and they just
swap things out and they swap things out
if they have those devices and if
they're allowed to get those codes their
repair goes much more smoothly are we
talking about things like
that if there are systems that kick that
that require even if he had a code
reader and could get the the code the
right way and and I've got to say
they're very common I've got one myself
but what happens is the one at the
dealership will give them several suble
levels of detailed information that the
generic one will will only give them a
ballpark okay and and sometimes the
depth of those codes the depth of them
is not revealed because it may contain
proprietary information about subsystems
that would allow a competitor to get an
advantage and it's just like any other
company where you want to keep your
Trade Secrets uh for as long as you can
so that you can have uh benefit in the
market and I don't look down on any
company wanting to do that however uh
the consumer needs to know that that's
what they're getting into so it's not
the codes themselves
it would be the system but I can see
where you're getting at with the reader
question but it's it's more in depth
than that and I further question inquire
or would you believe
it's maybe it's a would you
believe fair
enough I had to
design a reader system for an MP for the
Army and it turns out you can buy the
manuals that give give you that indepth
detail right down to the nitty-gritty if
you take your time to go get it it's not
that it's hidden you have to go find it
and and so I'm
questioning I I I've just dealt with so
many dealers over the years that just
don't take the effort to do it you know
if the reader gives it to me then I'm
I'm good if I have to go search for
anything I'm not going to be
bothered so are we trying to correct for
people being lazy I'm not clear that
wouldn't be the intent no
would you
believe okay representative Gibbs thank
you Mr chair uh in reference to the
previous question aren't you talking
about uh proprietary information that
the uh repair shop down the street can't
get hold of because the company will not
provide it in any form
correct okay we all set
thank you very much thank you Mr chair
and thank you committee and I have no
other cards oh
someone that would be
wonderful uh afterwards but introduce
yourself and let everybody know that you
represent the
manufacturers thank you Mr chairman you
turn the mic on and hold it really close
there we go all right okay perfect uh
thank than you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Mark Brown Advantage government Affairs
I represent the alliance for automotive
Innovation uh that is the trade
Association that represents the
manufacturers that produce most of the
vehicles in the United States the supply
chain
technology uh batteries uh
EVS autonomous vehicle technology you
know kind of the whole gamut uh we do
oppose the bill um not going to read
testimony I submitted written testimony
yesterday to you all um there was a a
memorandum understanding reached in July
of 2023 with the Automotive Service
Association and the society for
collision repair specialist when it
comes to rer repair um and it it states
on inly that independent repair
facilities shall have access to the same
Diagnostic and repair information that
autom manufacturers make available to
authorize dealer networks so we see this
bill as just unnecessary I guess and
there are over 30,000 Parts um in an
automobile you know between software
hardware and just the physical parts
themselves so trying to label those you
know much of it is proprietary so I
think that would be kind of difficult to
uh delineate all those individual parts
and uh what they may mean now that does
not mean that you know aftermarket parts
can't be used in repair they can it just
means that the information is
proprietary um and I'm not sure how we
would resolve that issue so I just
wanted to clarify those those few things
again we we did submit written testimony
and I'm happy to answer any questions
happy to work with the committee and the
sponsor represent Ammon has a question
thank you Mark for coming and testifying
um is there a I I have a question
industry n clature so first question uh
is there an industry term for like a sub
assembly representative splain was
talking about the transmission versus
the drivetrain versus you know the
exhaust system is there
I don't know but I I don't know but I'll
ask and try to get that answer for you
all right and then
um the second question was is there a
term for a part that can only be
repaired by the dealership is there
because proprietary seems to me to be
too broad of a term is there a term that
applies just to a part that you need to
go to the dealership to get it fixed I
guess I'll answer that question by
saying you know in our testimony and my
discussions with representatives from
from the auto Alli from the Auto
Alliance the auto innovators excuse me
to their knowledge there is no repair
that requires a vehicle to be repaired
at a dealership if that makes sense I
hope that I hope that answers your
question I I don't know if it does
but I
can if you want to yeah can I for the
for the question on that yeah that's
kind of where I'm going is how do we
Define it in law right um so a dealeron
repairable part whatever the term is for
that I guess there's two two ways it
could be dealer two ways that I can
think of right now um one is the
diagnostic information might not or the
the diagnostic tools or you know the
particular comp computerized device that
tells you what's wrong with
itb2 well right that's that's an
industry standard that's one way and
then the other way would be um you know
if there's a a code or an encryption key
that you need to in order to install say
a software chip or something I believe
this me this memorandum addressed that
issue like independent repair shops do
have availability that that information
available they may choose not to
purchase it um and they may choose not
to purchase a certain tool you know
that's necessary to make a certain
repair but the information is available
to them right
now okay so that I'm focusing right on
line 19 which says any repairs that can
only be made out of
dealership that you're saying is that
that contention is then if that's what's
left in the statute then this you're not
going to you're not going to put this
Ticker on because as far as you're
concerned anything can be repaired
somewhere else correct yeah I I guess
that would be the answer to that
question okay thank you very much I'll
fill the pin card thank you all right
any oh representative txon has a
question I'm sorry I I have a would you
believe yeah email so
so I I'm I own a 1923
Franklin and in on the firewall between
the engine and the front of the car it
says manufactured by the HH Franklin
Manufacturing Company of Syracuse New
York and then it lists about three dozen
patents patent numbers yes in the old
days they put the patent numbers right
there and then if you go to the manual
for the vehicle on the second or third
page
says to summarize there's a whole bunch
of stuff in here that we have patents on
and we make our own tools for and if you
want anything fixed properly feel free
to call your friendly local neighborhood
Franklin
dealer and if you can't find it or fix
it and you bust it don't call
us um and then just so we go maybe that
was unique to Franklin I also am the
happy owner of a 1950 packer before you
go too far you do realize that patents
expire I do but the point is and they've
got patents that will expire too soon
enough soon enough but the the point is
this isn't a new situation this is as
long as people have been manufacturing
automobiles there have been proprietary
tools and
proprietary I mean Franklin sued Alcoa
and one you know uh what yeah what they
settled for a dollar and whole bunch
ofum but that's must been casting it was
a cast casting debate yeah okay so the
point is there's a whole bunch of this
isn't a new Pro this is I understand
that technology modern technology is
baffling and you can't fix it in your
backyard anymore but I don't think
therefore would you believe I don't
think this is a necessary piece of
legislation thank
you thank you very much for your
testimony thank
you oh representative gives has a
question thank you um uh this is should
be a simple question uh you mentioned
anou that would have information that
can be purchased by the independent
repair shop um thatou I would assume is
between the manufacturers Association
and someone else who is the other party
it's the Automotive Service Association
and they represent independent
independent repair Specialists thank you
yeah and just so you know the the major
issue was the testing equipment and the
tools so with that we will close the
public hearing so we have no more
questions
this clock is fast all right we ready
you ready I'm ready
okay all right we have a do I have a
card bin
uh right here oh I do okay come on come
on
up come on up
so Ben how long have you been a state
representative 25 years don't answer
that right so you're he's he's with me
he's with you yeah we've known each
other he's with me he's not with
you as Democrat or is from Manchester
both both and never once have you
invited me out for
[Music]
lunch we'll have to fix
that I just remember the massages you
used to have you used to have those yeah
the uh but what was those no he had he
would bring in
the massage therapist yeah the massage
therapist now I have acupunctur
you want the massage people we bring
back call the alternative therapies
actually I stopped that during Co all
right what do we got
today um well Mr
notifications yes thank you Mr chairman
and uh members of the committee I'm
representative Ben brudi uh from
Manchester representing Hill 41 which is
Manchester's Wards 68 and nine
um this is a very simple bill it
shouldn't be
uh this is got a long history that I'm
not going to bore anybody with but um
basically what this does is if um a
retailer has a credit card company
servicing credit cards or given credit
cards with their name on it and they
want to switch providers that they offer
a 90-day notice
so when they send out their bill for
this month they'll say in 90
days this other company has taken over
that's all this bill
does it's to notify the consumer that
someone else is going to be sending you
their credit
card and that way it'll give somebody a
90-day notice to if they don't want to
do business with that new bank to
switch it it really shouldn't cost
anything and it's just making the
consumer aware aware of what's going
on I asked for one minute that's about
it if you want me to go into long detail
I can well I I guess give us a give us a
u an example of how this has been a
problem okay I mean what why is big
problem we need to legislate for this
about 12 hours a month in four different
courts I do mediation for small claims
and civil red cases okay and I hear
people complain about this all the
time I had a $700 credit card and then I
get a bill for $4,100 I can't pay it I
don't know what to do we're in court
something's going to happen you're going
to see the man
today so I just never knew how to help
anybody until something happened to to
me and that's why I'm on the bill by
myself because this is how I was aware
of what was
happening I was getting my gas if you
might w't mind me mentioning names uh at
BJs because they were the cheapest
around and they're usually in towns
where I
go and so I had a BJ's credit card
because I got 10 cents
off so and I don't know if you get them
but I get things in the mail maybe twice
a week sometimes with Capital One trying
to have me use one of their credit
cards I mean I could get three a week
you know I don't want to use Capital One
I had a bad experience with them long
long time ago and I want nothing to do
with
them so all of a sudden I get instead of
a flyer saying you know join Capital One
I get an
envelope there's something hiding it
there a card so I opened it up it's a
BJ's credit card with Capital One on
it with a bill for 300 and something
dollars just under $300 I called them up
I said I didn't want this credit card I
didn't authorize this credit card I
don't want this credit card I don't want
to do business with
you and I really don't want to pay for
late fees and service charges on a bill
that I didn't know I had
with
you well they they roundabout way they
said well $88 is for an automatic
renewal with
BJs I said all right I'll I'll give it
the $88 for if I sign something saying
it was an automatic renewal which I
shouldn't have done because actually my
lawyer still working on
it but yeah I wanted to be a member of
BJs I don't go in the store that often
but I was getting the gas there so
anyway I got a $300 bill from Capital
One a bank I don't want to do business
with if I knew that was
coming or if anybody knows that
something like that's going to happen
they can go out pay off a credit card if
they owe money or get somebody else so
that's where it came from I heard it for
years in court now it finally is on my
desk and that's why I think a 90-day
notice does doesn't hurt anybody you
want to send out a bill say in 90 days
from now it's going to be serviced by
this other
bank it's up to the consumer to do
something at that
point so is this a problem with the
credit card or with
BJs well I think it's a combination of
things BJs is doing business they they
want to sell gas they want to store and
sell things in their store they had
Symphony
bank with their credit card with their
name on credit card Sy fine symy Bank
yeah okay see that's yeah so I never had
a problem with it so I never had to
pronounce it
before but now if I knew I was going to
be paying
BJs I would have said no thank you I
don't want your credit card I don't want
to you know I wouldn't do be business
with BJs anymore in fact I haven't since
this
started and they do have the cheapest
gas around
so okay representative solivan yeah
thanks um
so do you know or have you done research
prior to making this bill what if any
standards there are is there are you
telling me that there is nothing on the
books about whether or not there is any
notification period or do you want to
extend a notification period from 30
days to 90 days like what is what is the
current rule is there anyone well I
didn't get any notification and I don't
know of any I know I I called the
banking commissioner and he said he
can't do anything because they're
federally charted and uh there's nothing
we can do about federally charted Banks
but I mean something like this you can
New Hampshire residents have a right to
know if service is going to be switched
but um is it another question for the
question me inquir is it is it possible
that something was sent in
notification and and it was lost in the
mail like maybe Capital when had sent
something to you you thought it was just
some sort of offer you threw it away
because I throw those things away all
the time well basically I do too I get
it from the mailbox it never makes it in
the
house I guess I think they have to I
think the the store the the uh where
you're you're shopping I think they
should tell you I mean if something came
from BJs I would open it it comes from
Capital One i' get a couple of week
that's going into garbage before I get
in the house I don't want to deal with
them yeah I I guess I'm just you're
right it could curious I'm just curious
if there is any standard now and I think
that would be important for us to know
before we make a decision on this bill
because if there is a standard and yours
fell through the crack somehow then we
might not need this but maybe there is
no standard in which case this would be
warranted but it sounds like we don't we
don't know the answer to that question I
I don't but if it happened the way I
said and say BJs did send me
something I don't pay attention to them
so maybe I did fall through the crack
but there's got to be a different way to
do it and I think whoever's
the end you know the originator of the
debt should tell you we're not using
this Bank anymore we Us in this
Bank
thanks representative
buroughs thank you I was just I was
wondering if you excuse me if you could
clarify I think you said that you saw a
one of the bills go from $700 to
$4,100 oh I see those all the time but
how did that happen with the new vendor
how did it jump from well I don't know I
mean I hear credit card complaints every
week I'm in court maybe once a week I
cover five mornings a month in court out
of the five mornings I'll probably hear
seven or eight complaints about credit
cards about how people can't afford them
how they don't understand the bill they
don't understand where the money's go
you know it's it's all
interest sometimes two-thirds of their
bill is interest and
penalties late fees and interest so
follow brother question so you're saying
that that this particular one jumped
from 700 to 4,100 because of interest
and if so over what period of time well
by the time it comes to my desk when
they come in for
mediation the lawyer representing the
credit card company doesn't know or not
the credit card company that the company
who buys the debt from the cred card
company there now it's another third
person they just buy the debt they can't
tell you what you bought when you bought
it they bought the debt they didn't
buy all the paperwork that went with it
before so they can't even tell you and
the judge isn't going to want to hear
the judge is going to say this company
says they owe you
this and the judge can't tell you where
the debt came from what you bought when
you bought it how much you bought it
for all they can tell you is what the
debt was sold to this third party for
lvnv funding is one that I know of uh
portfolio is another company um you must
you must know more you know all of them
but they're all collection
people and they don't have the
background of the debt so they're
cranking up the interest
rate I don't know where they get that
they just keep pumping it up and the
interest rates are pretty high on credit
cards and I see credit card problems
accelerating in the next couple years
can I just say one quick thing keep
going no I guess my question is if we
don't have any
idea where how it got from A to B I'm
not sure what we can do to fix
it well that's that's not what this bill
does but I wish we did have something
that did that now you're now you're
getting into a federal
situation you know when when the credit
card when a credit card comes company
says you owe this much money they hand
it off to a collection agency all they
hand off is the debt they don't hand the
whole file over these lawyers can't tell
you where the debt came
from represent
M yes
represent thank you and do I understand
you said when you're you had a a BJ
credit card with synchron I think and
then you got a uh a bill in a credit
card from uh BJs but it was Capital One
but did the balance that came over which
was just under $300 was that your
original balance or did they change it I
didn't have a balance with BJs now how
in the heck did they but Capital One
said $88 of that bill was for an
automatic renewal with BJs for a member
membership which I I can understand that
I would automatically renew it but I I
wouldn't automatically renew it with
BJ's number
one I don't have anything I signed years
ago when I first took out my account
with PJs what I signed I don't even know
if it's an automatic renewal I know I
just pay it when the bill comes in
they'll say $88 from membership they
send that once a year you pay
it so I don't know what I sign sign when
I signed it but it wasn't recently but
but your bill was for 300 bucks where
did the extra money come from interest
and late
fees but you always paid your bill on
time how did they get the interest and
late fees it was interest and late fees
on a Capital One bill because he was
throwing the Capital
One statements in the trash no I was
throwing all their brochures all their
all their advertising stuff went in the
trash it said Capital One you threw it
out well I probably
did because there a company I didn't
want to deal with and I didn't want to
read their
brochures so so the The $64,000 Question
is so when
BJs they never sent you any
notification that they were
now
uh using you use instead of whatever
credit card you had on file for whatever
bills you had that they were switching
you over to a Capital One account no saw
anything they so this is a merchant
problem it's a merchant problem it's not
a credit card problem it's that BJs did
not properly notify you that they were
sending that they had they had
automatically signed you up to a Capital
One account even though you never said
yes to it cuz you wouldn't you would be
a whole day in hell that you would ever
sign up for Capital One n and they
decide to charge your annual fee just
like we all have Amazon Prime and we get
our annual thing and they charge it to
the credit card that we have on file
yeah they
somehow not
only not only didn't notify you that
they created a Capital One account for
you and build it to the Capital One
account that unbeknown to you you never
got a notification that they did that
no representative
Gibs thank you Mr chairman uh just to be
sure I understand um this bill does not
attempt to fix any any of the problems
you've been describing with differences
in credit card charges no uh it only
provides for notice that the type of
credit card is going to be changed
that's it thank you representative pelli
thank you uh thank you for letting me
ask the question I had similar concerns
that you just raised that it's not
necessarily the credit card company but
it is the merchant that is co-branding
with the credit card company to go
through the process that you just
described so where would the notice
ification be in a separate letter on a
prior statement I think that needs to be
a little clear and I'm again I'm not
sure that it's the credit card company's
responsibility but the you know the like
you're saying the merchant that's
Contracting with the credit card
company well I think it could be a
combination of things like BJs could
have sent me something saying to a
switching because I would have opened
the BJ's thing or the bank that was
servicing the account before on one of
their bills like the third bill before
it changed saying as an EST State when
no longer going to service this
account as long as there's some notice
out there that makes the consumer aware
that something was going to
happen Okay so do you do business with
BJs I haven't since this no I saying
prior to all this happened
yeah you do business with I got
exclusively gas because unless I was out
of stage did you ever shop at BJs I have
okay
so is there a potential that you bought
something that was rather expensive and
they said if you want to sign up for a
credit card we can give you 10%
off does that ring a bell no
I know that if I use the capital the U
BJ's credit card at the gas pump I got
10 cents a gallon off
right but you don't remember in going in
and buying something at BJs where they
said you can sign up for a credit card
oh years or 10% about the sign up the
credit card because I
know we don't necessarily necessar pay
they they give you an opportunity to get
10% off if you sign up for something do
you remember any of that maybe years and
years ago I don't remember when I first
signed
up okay uh
representative Gibbs again thank you uh
just again to be sure that I understand
um the bill says that the Creditor shall
provide not notification to all holders
of such credit card and the Creditor is
the merchant
so the notice would have to come from
the merchant is that correct I believe
that's the way it was written
so if BJ sent me a notice
saying the credit cards will now come
from Capital
One as of this date I would have
declined taking it I declined taking it
anyway but they sent it to me representa
spear would you believe I've had a very
similar problem with Capital One exactly
as you describe it and it was horrendous
getting out from
under just what you believe so what was
the
merchant oh
God I think it might have been Long's
Jeweler you bought something in Long's
Jeweler and unbeknown to you you thought
you were getting a Long's Jeweler credit
but actually signed you with Capital One
I did get out from under it but it took
quite a while and I I had to go to Longs
and complain a
lot course they want to sell jewelry so
they don't they're amable to the
complaints but nonetheless it has
happened where somehow Capital One gets
into it I don't know what they're
doing uh you got to read the fine
print okay any other questions from the
committee
members see none thank you very much for
your testimony well thank you for your
uh
we
have anybody else would like to
testify on
okay all
right John excuse me actually actually I
do remember I paid for it with American
Express the and the bill came in on
Capital
One oh
godal
um theoretically we're you know I the
gavel is down I really we can't
technically talk about this bill at this
moment
the public Hearing in
1538 and here once again from the
distinguished representative from
Manchester
Manchester thank you Mr
chairman I'm still Ben Bui from
Manchester
um this this is um call it the sister
bill it again has to do with credit
cards this does have to do with credit
cards um a lot of complaints that I've
heard and uh I've
seen where people get charged $25 late
fee plus interest on
a15
bill I think that's
expensive um I I don't see any need for
that that they're just gouging the
public doing stuff like that I mean if
you owe a dollar or five dollar or
whatever why should they be able to
charge you 25 or
more that that doesn't make any sense
they don't have a lot of skin in it they
don't have a lot of investment in
that transaction and somebody May pay a
bill and not pay the full balance and
say well
that that bill is paid and I don't use
it anymore so I know I use Macy's credit
card around Christmas time and then I
pay it off in January and I get stuff
from acy's and I know I don't have a
balance so but if I owed them a $150 why
should I be charged over $20 or $30 for
a a small balance that's what this build
does okay this one I know something
about oh all
right educate us Mr chairman so I've had
moments because I I sit down once a
month to pay all my credit card
bills and I won't mention which
financial institution but I because they
had changed their wind their system
somewhat but I sometimes
forget to actually go to the next screen
which says pay
it so I think I paid my credit card B I
went online I did everything but I
didn't hit to pay it and I'm too busy
transferring the information over to my
spreadsheet cuz I keep a spreadsheet of
all my credit card bills and then when I
paid them and what they paid and then
the following month I get that
notice that said I didn't pay my
bill so I duly called them up and said I
am so sorry I thought I paid
it and loone behold
hold they will always say we can credit
you for the late payment fee because I'm
now calling on the
phone but we can't wave the credit card
the the
interest but they
always 100% of the time have always
credit me for the late payment
fee but I do have to pay resp you have
to pay the the interest your bill you're
just looking for the late payment fee
right not sure yeah well and other uh
other charges oh so you also want the
interest interest I can understand if
they're carrying if they have money
invested right no matter how much it is
their money's invested they have a right
to get interest on that money that they
have the interest for a
$150 is not going to be that much well
and but they always have waved but
here's the thing you got to call right
away you can't
delay well when do you call what the
next when you get when I get the next
statement the next following the F the
next following monthly statement when I
get that
statement I see that I have I I screwed
up and it didn't get paid and so
therefore they'll say to me no problem
on the late payment fee will wave that
and sure enough that does show in my
following month statement but the
interest I'm still on the hook for you
have a good bank you deal with I'm
telling you this is I have multiple
credit card companies and including
Chase
City uh uh what's the one my wife had um
uh every you unbelievable amount of
credit card I have I have literally I
have a I don't have use my bank America
much anymore but I would have I right
now I would say easily I have eight
different credit
cards credit card questions from the
committee
members
okay so it wouldn't hurt to just put it
in under the statue of the credit card
statue and no they're these ferally
chartered we the first answer you got
you on the first bill was the right
answer these are federally chartered we
can't do anything about federally
chartered
Banks
about well the the when I talk to the
banking commissioner that could fall
under
this because it's a federally charted
but you know yeah consumer protection
yeah yeah yeah but what if it's not a
federally charted Bank uh you want to
screw New Hampshire Banks well I don't
want to screw on New Hampshire citizens
no but I'm just saying you would you
want to you want to let federally
Charter Banks get away with something
and but only make New Hampshire Banks
pay for I think we should talk to our
people running for office right now and
ask them about it if they'll want to do
something about it because I've talked
to a couple of them yeah and they're
scared to death of them and all their
money and all their
lobbying okay and little you know
consumer has nobody speaking up for him
that's why I'm
here
you just got to pay your credit bill on
time that's
all some people can't I hear
you I understand and I'm respectful of
that any
questions see none thank you very much
okay thank you this bill evidently
generated no this is not the bill this
is a whole different bill more no 1538
yeah yeah know anybody else wants to
testify on
1538 see none I will close the public
hearing by Ben great to see you
Ben
curing on 1694 and represent n Welcome
to the Commerce Committee thank you so
much thank you Mr chair and thank you to
the committee members for uh allowing me
your time and attention today I didn't
realize I was going to be here uh before
the Cannabis spoke so um excited about
that I am here representing chesher 4 in
Kean to speak with you about my proposal
to form a study commission around the
impact of a public Bank in the state of
New
Hampshire while this bill does not
prescribe a specific structure or scope
I will be referencing the the benefits
uh in existing the existing structure in
North Dakota and proposed structure in
many states counties and municipalities
across the
country in discussing the concept of a
public bank it's become clear to me that
not many people in spite of its uh in
spite of the century old Bank of North
Dakota and the ongoing efforts to create
public banks in many other places folks
are not very familiar with the
concept yet in so many instances it has
occurred to me that a public bank is The
Logical solution to managing Financial
challenges in our communities with that
in mind I'd like to uh share just one
example in my own experience that hits
very close to home and I think it will
illustrate my intention for you at a
recent meeting of our regional Planning
Commission I listened as representatives
of several towns in the area gave
updates on the status of both
infrastructure
improvements uh and damage repairs which
were needed in the aftermath of
increasingly severe
weather the latter I trust is just as
acutely uh resonant to each of you as it
is to me whether your own Road has
washed out or you've seen for example
wm's uh recent footage of the historic
flooding along our Coastline these
repairs in particular are unpredictable
unavoidable and extremely costly
fortunately as was noted in the meeting
uh in the case of natural disasters FEMA
can provide relief
eventually so that caught my attention
so after the meeting I approached one of
the folks speaking on this to inquire
further as it turns out the process of
applying for in receiving FEMA grants is
a uh a very lengthy one often leaving
municipalities waiting for this
financial relief for up to two full
years of course the residents and
businesses in that town can't wait to
repair this damage so what do they they
do well the the answer they borrow they
take out a loan of course to this I
asked if FEMA would cover the interest
paid on the loans in the interim in the
two years where they're
waiting um the answer of course not with
a little chuckle at the absurdity of my
question the notion of absurdity is well
taken in the current structure very
little is within our control we are left
to take the hits compounding expensive
uh expenses for a citizen
in our efforts to maintain the services
we all depend on only to fatten the
wallets of the shareholders and CEOs of
the big
Banks however I would argue given the
alternative um of a public Bank where
transparency is ensured interest rates
are based on the minimum required for
operations profit any profit is invested
back into our communities and executive
salaries while comfortable are
determined by a charter that we and new
Hampshire create so while I am not an
expert on finance and I don't claim to
be I am a rational human being the head
of my household and a taxpayer in this
state where we are very much um where
where we very much pride ourselves on
our fiscal responsibility and with that
in mind I would ask you to vote in
support of a commission that would
provide a clear view of what a public
Bank could offer to the state of New
Hampshire and the and the citizens
within
it
okay
um Ling any questions um you did you do
any research
about the Comm us how many times we've
looked at this
issue uh yes and I would like to look at
it
again I'm I'm sorry can you tell me
exactly what you're referencing well I
guess is um you know how when we vote a
bill you know we have a on the public
record you know in the
calendar and we would then tell what the
commit committee's position on a bill
and I was wondering whether you had ever
look back at seen because I mean I
obviously I'm I'm a bad example that
I've been here way too long but
but this is like you know the sixth time
we've had this issue in front of this
committee so I was just wondering if you
actually look back at the last couple of
times we've done this and why the
committee has decided not to pass this
legislation I followed the bill last
year
so okay I saw that you voted against
it and do you remember thanks for your
time you remember what what we wrote in
the uh
report why why
we didn't go forward with this
legislation well this is a study
committee but why we
never we've gone forward with this issue
have you would you like to tell
me uh uh I could you don't need to it's
it's okay clearly um thank you for your
time uh we do have another question if
you want to take a question
representative Herbert um I'm a little
familiar with public um i' I've
researched it and it's very difficult to
get uh uh in this particular environment
uh a fair
hearing and uh for example the public
Bank of North Dakota which started in
1919 and it was as a result it was an
Agriculture state but it the resulting
problem that they were trying to solve
was the fact that they couldn't get
access to Transportation because the the
transportation system was owned by other
people who were not interested and so as
a result of that they went around the
farmers did and uh legislated a public
bank and it's one of the best run banks
in the United States it's it's its
record is remarkable and one of the one
of the nicest things about a public
bank is that it helps a lot of a lot of
City Banks or small Municipal Banks and
Credit Unions because it can once it's
once it's in business it can actually
add or expand the amount of money
available to the uh citizens and and as
you pointed
out much more quickly than FEMA and so
as a result of that I was in favor at
that point in time of uh having a study
of an honest study of uh banking public
banking because public banking is about
40% of all the banking in the
world now the fact that the United
States has one bank and it's obviously a
great bank but there is no uh political
support or it's suppressed to have the
people get to vote on whether or not we
should have a public
bank so it gets in the butt and it gets
nipped in the butt all the time and
that's because the existing political
leadership is against it so don't take
it
personal you know if it's
politics beginning and end and it's very
difficult
to uh it's very difficult to
uh have this
legislation uh accepted or were actually
seriously considered last time around
they went ran up to Dartmouth and they
got a Rockefeller to uh uh fund a a an
essay basically it was an essay it
wasn't economics document that it
wouldn't work and I read it and I'm
thinking this doesn't say anything so
you have one vote here all right thank
you and uh I think you should get a
chance to see if you you can EXP expand
that because I like the way you
presented it and I like the way you
responded to some of the comments uh of
the chair thank you Mr chair thank you I
appreciate your kindness and and
civility
honestly thank you representative
buroughs um this is a would you believe
uh would you
believe representative Herbert that um
in terms of this not being a fair
getting a fair hearing I think that this
is probably the most bipartisan
committee if not the most it is one of
the most bipartisan committees in in
this house and I think that all bills
get a fair hearing thank
you represent
Ammon thank you Mr chair thank you for
your testimony today um I guess this is
a would you believe just uh because we
had we have studied this issue before um
one of the would you believe one of the
objections to this is that it would take
a very long time for the bank to become
profitable and and because banking is
such a competitive industry there's a
large uh chance that it could fail and
if it fails the taxpayers would be on
the hook for cleaning it cleaning up the
the problem so in the past as we've
looked into this issue that that's the
main objection to it and I just want to
communicate that to you thanks yeah I
just I apologize I did have someone else
who was going to be here and speak and
they had a death from the family so
unfortunately I'm just
me representative spear this is also
would you believe the uh president of
the Utah BL the Dakota uh bank had
written a paper a few years ago and he
said it would cost approximately $100
million to start up a bank a public bank
they were able to do it back a hundred
years ago because it didn't take that
amount of money today he said and you
have to run it like a regular bank and
this was from North Dakota they said it
themselves this is not an easy thing to
start up and I don't think we have a
hundred, hundred million dollars to do
it but the other thing he pointed out
that John uh our chairman pointed out
was that a lot of the things that public
Banks do we have in facilities and you
you can describe that but uh having
facilities in our banks already and I
think that maybe a few words about that
might be
helpful okay so yeah so in terms of what
the State Bank in North Dakota does
which notwithstanding its initial
purpose was agricultural loans and
fortunately we actually have a bank here
in conquer that does agricultural loans
but not withstanding um it's the
business Finance
Authority and um actually they changed
their name so I I I kept trying to
remember the name because I heard it but
uh the student loans it used to be nefa
but it's now called something else but
that we in terms of giving facilitating
student loans these are all the things
that the North Dakota State Bank does so
we do have the facilities that provide
all the same services that the the State
Bank provides but in terms of um when I
read
your uh Vision in terms of the study
committee um you know is that
um the the
um
uh for the purpose of uh excuse me the
duties uh transparency and public
benefit of a public Bank um obviously
your perception is that um we want a
bank that has that's more public about
what it does and how it makes its loans
and whether you know it it's not
secretive or something but um so uh
at the end of the day you know you the
goal of a bank you know is to make loans
that are hope you know to for the
citizens of New Hampshire and I would
think that all our banks do do that
whether they um as public or transparent
as you would like um I'm not sure
creating a uh a public bank is is going
to get you there so but in the end of
the day
when you ask me the question is why is
this never got off the ground was the
startup cost that you uh for to create a
bank today you know you need hard money
Hard Cash you can't bond for it you
can't borrow for it you have to you
would have the state would have to put
in serious money um and you know whether
the 100,000 seems a little on the 100
million was a little 100 million seems
on the high side my my memory was uh the
the the banking commissioner said it was
it's at least 10
million um to to start a bank but but
sorry this was the uh gentleman from the
bank president of North D who said 100
million uh what our local folks said I I
I don't remember so any so um our our
bank commissioner said that based on our
laws to the state of New Hampshire that
you know it it would be at least 10
million doll so for the state to to get
it off the ground thank
you representative Herbert would like to
speak again and I hope you won't throw
me under the bus a second
time so uh you know bus throwing is not
a skill of mine but uh the um I am I
would be interested in knowing uh what
are um ability to
fund is uh another bank so in other
words is there uh liquidity in this
state that can actually fund the startup
of a uh public bank and my suspicion is
that there is plenty of liquidity and uh
and it's just political will so if it
was real popular if people realized all
the benefits a public bank has over
private Banks and there are a number of
them the the political will would be
different but it's very difficult under
the current legislature and and our
legislature is traditionally pretty
conservative um it's very difficult to
to get the uh the mo the impetus or any
kind of honest uh session I mean 1919
was a long time ago it was different
back then but they managed to do it a
bunch of farmers and now I'm sitting
here saying but we can't do it in New
Hampshire for somehow we're not capable
of creating a public bank and and it's
just political will we have the money we
have the ability we certainly have the
talent we were even told today that
there is a sort of bank for agriculture
already
here but that as far as you're going to
go and and I would I would support a
committee I would support somebody doing
some serious work uh on both sides in a
bipartisan fashion and uh see what what
comes out in the facts not normatives
what's the data and I'm I'm positive the
data and the facts make a very good case
for public banking in general not just
here
I guess that's a would you believe uh
representative
taon so I'm I'm going to take this under
the category of would you believe I just
forwarded an article to the
committee uh regarding Banking and new H
would you believe that New Hampshire is
the third most accessible state for
Banking and who who who made that
judgment forb Forbes magazine Maine is
first permont is second New Hampshire is
third the worst state South
Carolina uh and Breer would you believe
that when you take into consideration
things like the New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority the uh agricultural
Bank we the state of New Hampshire which
has always led the country in
banking um and solvency
has there's very little what's the
problem we're solving and I suspect that
the reason this may have not move
forward in a highly competitive industry
like banking which operates on a very
small
margin uh there's there's very little
profit and very little benefit so that's
my would you
believe
okay Representatives thank you thank you
Mr chairman thanks for taking your
testimony and putting it in the light
you did uh I appreciate that so one of
the tools that I'm learning to use since
I came back to the legislature after a
22-year absence is that search search
tool that I think representative
chairman Hunton was referring to um
it'll turn up for for next time or for
subcommittee work session and every bill
goes to subcommittee here um there's
about six other uh almost
identical pieces of legislation that
have come to this committee had a
hearing have testimony some might even I
don't think we had YouTube in 2019
because I think that was the most recent
one but there's a huge amount of
information about every other Fair
hearing that was here so my question is
did you happen to did you know about
that because I just learned about it and
I'm still figuring out the advanced
search which is a lot different than
like the simple search so it's a little
tricky to find them um in fact it took
me a while here just to do it to do it
now now um but that'll that'll help and
it'll might might push push the
committee in the right direction if you
wanted to take a look at that would you
believe okay thank you very
much uh I have one other card uh Ryan
held from the New Hampshire Bankers
Association
good afternoon I'll try not to take up
uh too much of the committee's time I a
lot of the points um committee members
have already made in my testimony but
again for the record uh my name is Ryan
hail vice president of government
relations for New Hampshire Bankers we
represent 40 member banks that employ
roughly 60,000 employees um you're right
this uh this issue has come before um
this committee um this will be I believe
the seventh time last year was the sixth
time um and I want to point to I believe
it's 2017 where there was a bill that
went to inum um referred to inum study
and I think the committee met five or
maybe six times um and the
recommendation was uh uh for no further
legislation um all the proposals uh
beyond that have either um have received
inex overwhelming inexpedient to
legislate recommendations including last
year which which was an 18 to1 vote with
a Voice vote on the house floor
um in my testimony that I have submitted
uh I've put in there uh questions that
we raised last year um along with our
answers the first one is there a need
for a public Bank uh FDIC has uh had a
did a survey in 2021 of unbanked or
underbanked households uh New Hampshire
I believe came in fourth uh uh lowest uh
at
1.4% um we have a very banked population
here in uh New Hampshire uh we also have
a thriving banking industry uh here we
have I believe in the past 10 years
three new Banks uh that have gone
through denovo
um will these the other question I pose
is Will These funds be
ured the past proposals were silent
whether or not this bank would need FDIC
Insurance think representative Ammon you
mentioned uh you alluded to this if a
state bank was to uh capitalize was to
be established and eventually failed who
would be on the who would be um on the
hook for that failure you know we can
look to Delaware in the 70s where they
had a state bank that failed and the
taxpayers were on the hook for hundred
million dollar hundreds of millions of
dollars um and then again the committee
uh members on the committee alluded to
this how will this Bank be capitalized
uh p proposals fiscal notes showed it
would need $50 million um the Nelson a
Rockefeller Center at Dartmouth back in
2016 uh did uh looked at this they said
63 million in California though much
larger landscape and more narrow scope
study it looked at a state bank for the
marijuana industry um they said a
billion dollars in capital and the bank
would lose money for 12 years and the
state would not see net dividends for 25
to 30 years after it was established so
in closing uh again the issue of
establishing a state bank has been
sufficiently studied and debated over
the years um and every time it comes up
the legislature has decided it's not
right for New Hampshire so therefore I
respectfully ask the committee to again
vote inexpedient to legislate thank you
for your time I'd be happy to answer any
questions representative Herbert has a
question for you uh this is not a
a private banking in New Hampshire is uh
successful MH not even questioning that
but there have been uh certain uh times
and periods of times U the last one I
can remember was I think was called The
Savings and Loan crisis which is from my
opinion uh or no my recollection is just
about
every Bank in New Hampshire
failed hamis
gone um
Merchants gone indan is saving Indian
Head
Gone
um I can't go through the whole list but
every one of them except for who was the
governor's Bank back then I have two of
those anyway there was one bank I do you
know the bank that the governor uh I
don't know the bank but I think you're
referring to back in the early 90s when
yeah sure it was a nashille bank but it
was uh it survived Y and my point is
during that same Savings in loan which
was a national problem the Bank of North
Dakota was one of the best to survive so
I'm not saying we don't have good
banking here in this state because we do
what I'm saying is that a public bank
has some different priorities that would
help smaller Banks and also I think help
the infrastructure work and a lot of
things that we need doing here in the
state which are not getting funded and
as for not having liquidity that's
nonsense well and not to you know while
they're not exactly Banks there are
Quasi government lending arms for
instance I know is mentioned the
business Finance Authority we have New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority and
representative hunt you had mentioned
what used to be NE which is now I looked
it up Granite advance for student
lending y so there are um while not
Banks there is Alternatives access to
Capital through um guess you would call
them quasi government arms yep and
there's there's a agriculture bank I
think in Bedford it uh are you referring
to Walden Mutual it does it's not Walden
it's basically is a like a a I can't
remember the name but it's specifically
in the name an agricultural uh
and I'm I'm not sure if it's part of the
government but I think it is
so I just think would you believe I
think there is room uh and and uh uh
advantage to having a mixed banking
sector and it's not just
private thank you very much you're very
welcome oh oh I'm sorry representative
taxon has a question
well I guess this is another would you
believe with with reference to and
please correct me if this is wrong from
your understanding but when we look at
the failure of the Savings and Loans in
the Savings and Loan crisis those were
primarily State chartered entities that
were inadequately capitalized because
State banking requirements were less
stringent than Federal requirements and
they weren't typically FDIC insured
having lived through them
and
uh the other thing is that those lenders
primarily made uh commercial real estate
loans all of which was impacted by the
Reagan roson
Kowski uh changes the tax code in 1987
which then gave you four years to
liquidate your Properties or recapture
things so that market collapsed
so the idea of having more State
state-owned Bank the is even more scary
when you look at it in light of that and
the fact that the bank in North Dakota
didn't fail or Montana whatever it is is
because it's primarily an agricultural
bank and it wasn't significantly
impacted by the changes the massive
changes in the tax code in 1987
that was my would you
believe that could be yes
no while I wasn't uh maybe while I
wasn't around that time um it is my
understanding that uh there was
concentration um in real estate um and
that uh I guess a response was were you
know the landscape's a lot different uh
regulations are a lot different uh
safety and sound of banks are a lot
different than they were back
then thank
you turning my mic
off thank you all thank
you I have no more cards and so I will
close the public
hearing and I have two different
clocks this is our clock that's science
and
technology so we'll wait a minute yeah
okay we'll wait two minutes satellite
all right got two minutes so if you're
going to testify please turn in your
cards so I know
who wants
to weigh
in that's right
exactly who Erica crime oh okay and her
husband I thought she made sense but
then I'm
bi I was I didn't know I
was my name's Riley and ien
Bre holy
mackerel okay awesome thank you
245 pharmaceutical
SCI pretty good
episode
all right let's open up the public
hearing on
1633 and uh if you haven't got your pink
cards in then you're gonna have to hand
them get them around and you're G to get
on the bottom of the pile okay so
represent L you are
up thank you Mr chairman and members of
the Commerce Committee it's nice to
actually be in front of this committee
uh for my first time um I want to thank
everybody who was involved in the whole
process of the commission over the
summer in order to look at a state run
model and try and see what the
challenges and problems were um it was a
very interesting and very complex issue
um and quite frankly I think that
there's some challenges that are
insurmountable um with that model and
that's why we brought forth this bill we
brought forth this bill because we
weren't sure if that commission was
going to be able to meet a resolution
and I lack confidence that having the
state that intimately involved in this
process is good for the people of New
Hampshire and safe for those people who
work for and represent the state
um this bill um is built off of the
house bill 639 framework that came out
of here um I do know that there were
some some changes and some other ideas
that happened in the commission that are
outside of the state run model um and
those may be an interesting thing to
discuss as we move forward but I will
walk you through some of the changes
here compared to what uh left this
committee and left Ways and Means last
year um the largest change is that
instead of having the excise tax this
would go into a rooms meals and cannabis
um tax because you're looking at a
product that grows and then is prepared
for people to consume much like a meal
and this would be a straightforward way
in order to handle the handle the
process streamline it through an
existing program and just sort of remove
one more layer of bureaucracy so that
that could happen within that same
framework um it's also a very good
incentive to sort of keep those levels
balanced um because as you have more
people across different sectors um
working within that there's more
pressure just to keep that consistent um
there are some other changes as well
some that would make it more friendly to
those who are coming and camping in our
C campgrounds making it clear that if
you're in your RV and it happens to be
on but nobody's driving it that wouldn't
be a oui incident because you have the
Heat or the radio on which under the
current laws and the current Way It Was
Written it would be um So within this it
does largely walk the existing path and
it also meets most but not all of the
goals set by both the governor and new
futures um the governor definitely seems
very intent on the state run model and a
very limited number of sto of stores as
an economist um I think that we need to
look at the fact that this is going to
be a very small Market by definition
unlike liquor we won't be buying any of
this across state lines so we'll need to
have both the people who are selling it
those who are processing it and those
who are growing it able to diversify
their risks throughout the entire
process um and when you're selling to a
monolithic block that actually increases
your risks as a grower especially
because as an Agricultural Product you
need to plant well before the demand you
need to be able to plan ahead of time
and have some expectation of what that
pricing would be if we got into any sort
of a pre-plant contract where the
state-run stores were Contracting all
the way down to when you're starting the
plants you know that makes the state
even more plant touching I know that the
Department of Justice has said that they
will not do interfere with the states
and their cannabis regulation but that
doesn't mean that other Departments of
the federal government are going to take
a similar hands off approach we actually
saw in um Georgia I believe the DEA
sending Cent assist letters to the
pharmacies that are now allowed under
Geor law to dispense THC containing
products so that is a new move from the
federal government to intervene in a
state license business and I think that
that definitely should bring bring some
caution to the idea of tying the state
too close to this process um know it's
uh there's some information I think that
there's some other people who have both
submitted testimony and some that'll be
speaking about where it does and where
it doesn't overlap with the guidelines
from both the governor and and new
futures um but in the interest of time
because this clearly is a bill with a
lot of interest I will just uh close it
at that and be willing to take any
questions uh need to say this committee
has heard this bill before so I guess we
don't have any questions so okay oh we
do have a question representative
Sullivan has a question thank you a
great gra testimony um so it looks like
you guys have this
this uh tax revenue earmarked for
certain things can you talk about that a
little bit oh yes thank you I'm sorry
that I glossed over that um this
actually would address a couple of the
issues that we that we're facing in the
state it would send some of the revenues
into the affordable housing Fund in
order to be able to address that ongoing
challenge we have in housing um it sends
most of it to the education trust fund
which is even more pressing with the
recent lawsuits that while this won't be
enough to solve our school funding
problem it'll be one more step to be
able to close that Gap and pay for our
schools by something other than property
tax and quite volunt quite honestly with
a voluntary tax um which is a better way
to to fund things um also it does have
some Provisions for water and sewer
expansions and by doing that you'll be
able to help help cover both the cost of
that infrastructure as new people and
new new um providers new people who are
involved in this market move in and also
add address some of those underlying
issues with um the constraints on our
current housing Supply so this is
designed to although it spreads the
money a little further it does address
some of the different needs in our state
so thank you for that
question keep us thank you very much
want to thank you chairman hunt for all
of your tireless work on this so thank
you
okay naita
here
co-sponsor Nita
burough not used to being on this side
looking directly at the chairman I'm uh
I'm State Rep Anita burrow I'm from car
from Carol to and I'll keep it brief cuz
there are so many people here today but
I I just wanted to talk very briefly
about why I think that this bill is the
best model for the Live Free or Die
State um the crafting of this bill
relied on the expertise of of many
people who have been in the industry for
many years um I've had people say to me
you grow it you dry it you roll it
that's all there is to this business and
nothing could be further from the truth
uh a number I think there are two of us
in this room at least that I know of
went to a uh uh a tour of an $8 million
uh cultivation facility in Maine and we
learned how complex this business is um
we learned that to grow to grow
consistent and accurate buds uh Growers
use different cannabis species under
very different growing conditions and
expertise is needed in areas of
nutrition water lighting and temperature
and humidity so it it is a complex
business um we also traveled to an
independent licensed cannabis store over
the Border in Maine and we met skilled
people who were were trained in the
dosage manufactur and impact of the many
products being sold so if you bought
something you were confident that you
knew what was how it was it could impact
you and what the dosage what the best
dosage would dosage would be for you um
we'll hear that today that cannabis has
pharmacological effects and and that you
do need people who can direct people
appropriately um now can the Liquor
Commission alone expect their employees
to live to deliver in this regard or
would it be better to have a li The
Liquor Commission working tandem with
with a cannabis commissioner I I would
say yes um if you visit it and if you
visit dispensaries in other state
including nearby Main and and um
Massachusetts you'll see that each each
dispensary has its own distinct
personality their own set of prop
products their own Ambience so the
question that we have here in New
Hampshire is do we want a McDonald's
type of franchise where everybody has
the same products the same store the
same layout or or will consumers do they
do now when they want a hamburger if
they're at they're short for time
they're going to run into a McDonald's
but other times they want something more
unique um they're going to see seek out
establishments such as The Barley House
here in conquer um um I didn't mean to
give them a plug but they do have good
burgers um so I I know the governor has
been talking about um a franchise model
where the state would regulate Marketing
sales and distribution um but I think
the question for this committee is do we
as a Live Free or Die State want want to
encourage oper entrepreneurs and a new
and small businesses and a new industry
here in New Hampshire or do we want to
set up a system in New Hampshire where
experienced individuals could run their
businesses as they see fit and grow them
without the the regulations um alibet we
do still need the we still need need we
still need regulations regarding safety
potency and keeping and keeping cannabis
out of the C hands of children um I
think I know I do and I know a lot of
people in this room would would feel
that we want entrepreneurs to choose the
location that they think would provide
them with the best shot to succeed and
to Market their products in a way that
Sears the personality of the store their
clientele and the this the community
that they're in um one thing that we
really need to think about is how much
money we're leaving on the table as a
state um Massachusetts has generated $5
billion and gross cannabis sales since
since their for for their stores first
open in 2018 uh in terms of just in
terms of the tax revenue they've gone
from 22 million in 2019 to 248 million
in 2022 um I think that's pretty
astonishing Maine is breaking record
sales on a monthly basis um they did 216
million in 2023 gross and uh $40 million
more than the previous year and they
generated over $30 million in revenue
and that that's only growing um so
whether or not you think that cannabis
is been is illegal in in New Hampshire
in some ways it isn't because anybody
who wants it is going over the Border
they're going to M Massachusetts they're
going to New Hampshire um and they're
buying products or they're buying it
from friends who have medical um medical
marijuana cards I've had I've had five
or six people say if you want some I'll
get it for you um I'm not going to do it
because I have legislative license
plates um but I can assure you that uh
there are legislators in this house who
are doing it and it's just a common
practice so we have to decide if we want
that business to continue to go out out
of state um and I'll just add a personal
note um I have um I've I have a minor um
problem I've had two surgeries for I've
had all kinds of medications none of
it's worked when I was in California I
had a gummy and my symptoms disappeared
and I was able to get a good night's
sleep for the first time in 20 years why
can't I get it I mean it just seems my
doctor can't write me a script because
my symptoms are not on the list of um
for medical marijuana so um I will just
say in closing that I think HB 1633 as
written is the best way that we can
ensure a robust Private Industry um that
can create jobs and contribute
significantly to New Hampshire tax
revenue okay uh represent M you has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative burls my question is just
about the one thing you mentioned which
is in regards to to the I think you've
said people to direct people
appropriately is that referring to
people in the various dispensaries or
retail outlets or whatever and if it
is what's their training are they
medical I mean they're advising on what
we've all said is medical and these are
Pharmaceuticals and there's a I think a
pharmacist or a farm D who's going to
testify and maybe I'll ask her but
what's who are these people how are they
licensed how are they trained to
dispense what's essentially Healthcare
advice I think I think that's a really
good question and I think that would be
better answered by the some of the
people who are coming behind me but um I
can tell you that the store in main um I
think the people behind the counter um
were trained um by people knowledgeable
in the industry but to give you a more
specific answer I'm going to I'm going
to punt that to people coming up behind
me
thanks thank you very
much okay uh chair we'll call on uh
let's see next uh Timothy Egan
I'll wait for the fine
representative good afternoon thank you
Mr chair thank you members of the
committee for hearing my testimony
Timothy Ean former representative from
Sugar Hill currently the chair of the
New Hampshire cannabis trade
Association thank you for taking time to
hear my testimony I did electronically
submit it as well
um and I will be able to actually
address the representative MC's question
to to representative Burrows regarding
training so let me get to that um today
I'm here as the chair of New Hampshire
cannabis trade Association the state's
leading trade group for cannabis
industry and we're pleased to support
House Bill 1633 its bipartisan
leadership of Representatives Leon and
Barrow to move New Hampshire into the
realistic world of cannabis use being a
faculty member teaching canab business
has made me understand the Cannabis
legislation is important as House Bill
1633 will create intelligent regulation
in the industry in the Cannabis World
regulation equals safety legal Growers
will have to follow rules to create Safe
products free from chemicals in the soil
or dangerous fertilizers legal process
will develop products for sale within a
structure that takes the business out of
the hands of the black market and legal
retailers whose employees must be
trained and guide customers will
safeguard consumers by letting them know
the ingredients and potency of the
products they want to produce being a
the university a university director of
internships in the Cannabis studies
certificate program at Vermont state
university has made me understand that
free market cannabis legislation is
important as House Bill 1633 will create
a new industry for New Hampshire it will
allow small farmers to be able to add
new crops to their Reven Revenue
generation efforts it will allow
processors to design new business
ventures that will invest in New
Hampshire's economic infrastructure and
it will allow retailers to create new
jobs support media Outlets with
advertising and draw more value for
tourists that visit our state 1633
understands that we are losing money
from New Hampshire residents to mass
Maine and Vermont New Hampshire can
reclaim this du Revenue jering industry
that almost 80% of our residents agree
with we are also seeing outdoor tourism
participants making new decisions on
where they visit and for how long they
visit they are choosing other states
because they have the outdoor
resources for recreation and they have
legal adult use
cannabis and we are seeing an industry
built on small business entrepreneurs
and agriculture in other states that
surround us one that is poised for
growth in being New Hampshire being
poised for growth in New Hampshire but
is being stifled due to inaction with a
strong percentage of the proceeds that
this bill has going towards education is
imperative that we act this spring to
pass it we are all familiar with the
recent Court ruling changing the way
that education funding will take place
in New Hampshire it will drive up school
taxes for towns it will pass passing
this bill will also be able to reduce
those tax obligations to reduce property
taxes on on Rising Education costs
whether they're in the form of public
schools or vouchers whatever way you
enjoy your education this will help it
be more
costeffective we can't ignore that this
bill was designed by a bipartisan
Coalition and by a bipartisan group of
legislators who are looking at Best
Practices it's a bill that has the best
in mind for New Hampshire and speaking
of Best Practices New Hampshire applauds
supporting a free market economy
remember a free market economy is an
economic system in which the prices of
goods and services are determined by
supply and demand expressed by sellers
and buyers such markets as modeled
operate without the intervention of
government or any other external
Authority it's time for New Hampshire to
pass intelligent legislation like House
Bill 1633 I thank you for your time and
hearing my testimony and I'm glad to
answer any questions would you like me
to start with representative mof's
question
M knowing that rules of any past
legislation for cannabis would be done
by the agency uh my reference is the
Cannabis control board within the state
of Vermont has a requirement that
employees must pass a certified exam of
nine parts to
be receiving their ID card for anyone
that is a customer facing employee some
of those include use
overuse body um other uh Pharmaceuticals
that you might be taking as well as
inventory management understanding of
potency understanding of the derivatives
of a product right THC versus CBD versus
cbdn so Vermont employees at any
cannabis retail establishment have to
pass this training by the state and
receive their ID card before they are
eligible to become a full-fledged
employee
is that
helpful sounds like an interesting
process they're doing in Vermont so they
they created an an a separate state
agency for training of no those
employees or within the association
sorry sorry I I know Tim so we chat so
sorry representative um thank you for
your question I'll be formal um they
actually created an ID card training
program within the agency so it requires
for people to take it they have
outsourced that to vendors the retailers
have to pay for their employees to take
that training test so it's on the
business it's incumbent on the business
not on the state to execute the test the
employee signs up takes the exam sends
their results into the into the state
they get their ID card and they are then
able to work at the register advise a
consumer
Etc
thanks
so maybe we'll talk about it in
subcommittee a little bit but I so what
I understand is that you're proposing
that similar
program before we allow these employees
to dispense what's essentially healthare
de healthc care advice on a
pharmaceutical over the counter much
like a pharmacist does in a little area
that says get advice here or whatever
you know at a pharmacist proposing the
same kind of
setup well knowing that legis isation
initially needs to be passed and that we
are very big on agencies creating
rulemaking that would be something that
would be incumbent upon the Liquor
Commission I would advise them if ever
asked an official capacity to do that
and would be glad to share the
infrastructure that Vermont set up I
think it's important they are probably
do some of that training now as well as
you know understanding are people
intoxicated if they're buying too much
liquor you know those are the things
that is coming upon a state agency to
run their regulatory
aspects this would be something that
could be implemented then once
a agency that is overseeing this presuma
the Liquor Commission in enforcement
would say here's what employees need to
have to be able to dispense it just like
when we go into a grocery store now and
you walk up to the register to buy beer
and the person under 21 is at the
register they have to ding the buzzer
and call someone over AG to over swipe
their card and sell
that that is a takes time and energy if
you could train employees who are above
21 to be able to have a education level
that
is enable enables them to engage the
consumer and understand the consumer and
be able to counsel them on maybe this is
not right for you maybe you're you know
you're taking other medications maybe
you shouldn't take this kind of potency
that's where that program could be
created could be a value to the consumer
and could be a valuable to the state the
businesses okay I'm going to I'm going
to and I'm glad to come to subcommittee
and okay talk more about this I'm going
to Stir It
Up this bill is very very similar to
House Bill 639 that this committee
overwhelmingly
supported sent to the floor
overwhelmingly supported on the house
and died
in the
Senate there is some
suggestion that if we go with a
different
model that was recommended by the
governor that the Senate might actually
pass it my question to you is what would
you rather this committee
do pass this
bill and have it die in the Senate or
pass a amended
bill that was somewhat agreed by the
commission and send it forward and see
what happens with that bill what should
the committee do I'm in favor of
legalization and regulation of cannabis
I'd pass any bill that allows that to
happen and I think what happens within
the interaction between the Senate and
the house is going to happen not with
with my input because it was not taken
by the commission I was never asked or
called to testify even though New
Hampshire can was listed so I in favor
of anything that moves legislation and
legalization forward because of all the
reasons I stated I'm open-minded I think
that's the way you build good
legislation is being open-minded to
hearing all parts perfect answer I try
thank you very
much oh representative s
um so yeah representative Leon did a
great job talking about some of the the
revenues I was wondering if you could
expand on it because it talks a lot
about how it's going to go into unfunded
liabilities and also do you have any
estimates does anybody have any
estimates about like we know that people
are consuming these products in our
state they are going across borders I
think that's not really a debatable
point do we have any idea what the
leakage is and what the capture might be
if if we were to pass this bill and how
that that captured money would be spent
to deal with the unfunded liability
issue that it says here on page 24 okay
I'll try to answer them in two parts the
first part I think unfunded mandates and
and
unfunded we have a serious issue with
pension funding for small towns which
adds which allows those towns and they
have to put that onto their property tax
whether that's for policemen firemen
EMTs teachers Town employees we have to
cover those uh what if I remember 68
years ago um that percentage of funding
by the the state was cut under a
previous legislative Administration and
that's hurt towns and I think this is
one way to help towns is new Revenue
that could go for that for P for pension
funding I think what's specifically
earmarked in the bill regarding
education is Paramount we do not fund
our community colleges well we do not
fund our state colleges well we do not
have a smart model for Education funding
here we're now in our third goor round
of potential Supreme Court decisions
around State funding since I've been
living in the state in since 2004 so
we're what's the definition of insanity
right repeating the same action and
expecting a different outcome we need to
do something different if this is a way
that it can change it can
change
potential Michigan just announced they
made $3 billion
within their second year of cannabis
sales they're using 30% of it for
Education
funding as it relates to your estimates
um last year I did an estimate using the
methods that the Department of Revenue
looked at in Maine and Massachusetts as
well as I assessed other states similar
size to New Hampshire and my estimates
on behalf of New Hampshire can were
somewhere between 18 and 25 Mill million
do of our Revenue leaving the state
that's New Hampshire residents driving
across the border I've since had some
conversations with a consultant out of
Colorado who told me it's double for the
it's double because your tourists are
coming in or your other whole operation
people that come in to buy it who aren't
New Hampshire residents so you're
looking at a first year only of
somewhere around $50 million now we're a
small
state but one of the things that we do
have our second leading industry right
now at about billion doll is the tourism
industry right outdoor tourism we
created a whole separate entity a
separate legal entity of an outdoor
tourism office that's a major focus of
our economics the governor touts are
great outdoor you look at the folks that
are outdoor
enthusiasts skiers snowboarders mountain
bikers hikers I know them they live in
the North country with me 3 to one 5 to
one they're going to choose cannabis
over alcohol
anytime I hope that was helpful thank
you
yeah okay thank you very much thank you
so much Mr chair for taking the time to
have me here representative
kahill who was opposed to the bill and
was a member of the
commission thank you Mr chair good
afternoon friends and colleagues and
friends in the audience obviously um I'm
here in total opposition to this bill
it's never the right time to put more
drugs on the streets of New Hampshire um
I just wanted to clarify a couple of
things all of our hearings at the
marijuana commission were open to the
public and everyone was welcome um I
didn't see too many of you guys at those
hearings but there's some really great
information at those hearings we had we
heard lots of testimony that might have
answered representative McHugh's
question about um you know whether
doctors can actually legally prescribe
this in in the state of New Hampshire
and stuff like that I think you were
asking along those lines um possibly and
the answer is no
um we just need to recognize that no
Futures and the governor aren't the only
voice that um in the state of New
Hampshire they don't make all the
decisions we have a huge population and
I would disagree with the um the
statement that 80% of the
population um wants marijuana sold in
the state I think if they knew the facts
and we actually honestly gave them the
facts about the hazards of marijuana and
and with our traffic fatalities the
actual stats on that which you can all
go back and listen to some really great
testimony but none of you none of you
were there for um but the marijuana
commission and I want to correct for the
record with with chairman hunt the
marijuana commission uh voted down that
proposed legislation um and that's all I
wanted to
say no they voted it down because more
than half the committee didn't
vote well a loss is still a
loss no I think it lacked a
quorum okay any questions representa the
spear hi uh I shouldn't say hi thank you
uh my question is this the there I live
right near Tings Boro and there is a mar
marijuana shop there and I see the lines
of New Hampshire cars going there do we
are we seriously pretending that people
don't want to to get marijuana from M
they're not doing it they're not getting
it from Massachusetts and they're not
getting it from verant and then not
getting it from Maine when in fact we
know they are because we see them
um I think you're right I think there
are people crossing States lines
illegally with marijuana into the state
of New Hampshire and and I don't think
that we should be saying that that's a
good thing I think we should be
enforcing our laws yeah there's there's
people smoking weed in this state but is
it a good idea I mean we can look at
examples of say the school shootings
from around the country almost
overwhelmingly all of the School
shooters have tested positive for
cannabis and there's lots of mental
illness problems from the use of it
cannabis
disorder it it's it's a fact the these
are
facts pusk has a question thank you Mr
chairman as a member of the
committee are you aware if there is any
successful test for marijuana
intoxication no um the chief's
Association was um raising those
questions in our hearing there's a good
couple hours of testimony you can go
back and listen to our conversation on
that um there's a few states that have a
couple of and that's a great point they
have a couple of testing systems in
place but there's no set guideline
there's no no same place as doing the
tests the same way there's there's not a
blood test or anything like that that's
out there it's
been qualified I I guess you could say
do I think we should have a test AB
absolutely I think New Hampshire should
lead the if we're going to legalize weed
we should have a test you know we we're
putting the horse before the cart here
you know we you know new Futures wants
this cannab cannabis Advisory board but
it wasn't it wasn't really their idea
there was a great lady that came from
California and testified on why we
should have that cannabis Advisory Board
and we should be establishing that
cannabis Advisory Board before we even
go f f further on this we should have
the testing so that we can uh enforce
our laws I mean we don't want people
driving on the road intoxicated with
cannabis representative Burrows no you
can't ask a question you spoke okay
representative Sullivan thank you so I
hear you and I understand that you're
concerned about the dangers of marijuana
I don't dispute that those dangers
exist I think the way I I think about it
and I want to share with you just to
sort of hear your opinion is you just
cited potentially you sort of kind of
made made a link we won't go whether or
not the link between shootings and
schools and kids smoking marijuana is is
a cause or effect type thing but the
fact that there are kids in school
smoking marijuana it's already illegal
in every state for people under that age
to do it so my question for you is about
this is people are already breaking the
law right and if people are already
breaking the law then that means that
they're getting marijuana somehow and
the marijuana they might be getting may
very well be more dangerous i' I've
heard about marijuana being laced with
things like fentanyl which can cause
people to die from an overdose right
away so my question for you
is and should be for everybody in this
room is what is the best way to do harm
reduction of something that we know is
not a healthy choice we we we have our
systems that we try to do that with
alcohol which having one drink is not
even good for you smoking one joint is
not going to be good for you what's the
best way to do it you seem to think
prohibition is the best way to keep it
out of the hands of of the youth and
keep our population safe and I think
that we could point to plenty of
anecdotes at least where very dangerous
substance gets introduced into marijuana
because it's unregulated so like what is
your take on that well you know at the
hearings which I sat in and you were on
the commission um you you weren't there
all the time just like chairman hunt
wasn't there all the time you guys had
other stuff going on but um I was
willing to work with a lot of people on
harm reduction and we didn't come to a
real agreement on
um anything that was strong enough to
protect the kids I mean and like fines
and penalties and things like that
they're not in here you're right our
kids are utilizing marijuana and I would
say and I would say that they're
utilizing the Delta 8 Delta 9 Delta 10
THC products that aren't really
regulated and or tested because we don't
have a lab to test those products in
this state you know I think
that
um obviously I'm completely opposed to
legalizing it in the state but if if you
everyone that came to those hearings I
was I was there working with all my
colleagues and having open dialogue we
don't have a lab testing facility to
test stuff we we would we would need
that up and running before any of this
should even be considered you know we
would need that cannabis Advisory Board
um those those the Cannabis Advisory
Board um would be able to work and do
harm reduction with the kids I mean but
overwhelmingly I think saying to all the
kids at home yeah let's legalize weed
isn't isn't a good idea you know what I
mean we should be keeping them off weed
we we know that men's Brains are still
developing until they're 25 years old
and we know that cannabis affects brain
development
follow okay so I hear what you're saying
you you were on the commission you you
are concerned about you're concerned
about um harm reduction but all the
things you just listed aren't going to
come unless we legalize it so whether we
want Labs we want testing facilities we
want The Advisory Board all those things
come from a path to legalization if
those things if those things would
actually reduce harm towards
children compared to an unregulated
system right now is that a better
outcome and I think that's the question
we need to think about because you're
not going to get those things without
legalization like that's just the
reality of the world we're
in while we could start enforcing our
laws
thank you very
much I'll talk to you upward I have
thank you yeah I have one more Mr
chairman may may I ask you a question
I've been trying to get your attention
there for a bit I'm sorry I was all set
with him wasn't I
now it's him he's asking oh you want
okay go ahead ask your question thank
you representative for taking my
question um and and thank for trying to
answer the the part about the
qualifications of the people dispensing
what
we're commonly referring to as a medical
product are so what I was I wasn't
asking about can doctors write it
legally I'm asking do did the Commission
address the qualifications of these
individuals as non-licensed or
non-healthcare people for the most part
basically clerks in a store we did
dispensing it
advice as somebody decides whether they
should buy this product or that product
that's commonly referred to by everybody
behind you as a medicinal product with
health care benefits essentially Health
Care advice right that's my concern is
we've got this this issue where in a
pharmacy the tech can't even hand you a
new prescription you've got to go see
the pharmacist if you've never taken
this brand of aspirin before even though
it's a prescription you have to go see
him but here we're talking about
something that has different I'm that's
I'm Wonder did you guys address that at
all we we did address that we we we had
all the
atc's sitting at the table and we asked
them lots of questions we heard from
medical doctors but we asked all the
atcs I mean I personally asked them um
if they had any doctors working in their
facility MDS and they didn't they do
they heard they do didn't there was zero
zero zero doctors working at the
facility so the rest of the employees
that were offering potential medical
advice weren't doctors
weren't really licensed in any capacity
and were could have just been a kid off
the street right you know I mean
hopefully a 21-year-old kid but um that
there really wasn't any kind of
program or real training that we were
shown that they were giving credible
medical advice there is no credible
medical
advice thank you very
much uh chair we'll call one one more
former reps who
H thank you Mr chair thank you for
giving me the opportunity I'm here
representing uh Sam New Hampshire Sam is
smart approaches to marijuana it's a
bipartisan Alliance of organizations and
individuals dedicated to a Health First
approach to marijuana
policy uh Sam New Hampshire opposes 1633
3 uh hb1 1633 and other efforts to
legalize because it will have negative
Health consequences and safety
consequences for granite Staters
particularly our youth according to the
methodology subsection in this bill
which documents the New Hampshire
Department of safety's concerns data
from other legalized States highlight
the following concerning factors
marijuana use in both Illinois and
Colorado has increased significantly
since legalization including minor age
children the average THC level in
marijuana products has Ren risen from 3
to 23% in smokable marijuana and from 56
to 99% in other forms such as waxes oils
and
Edibles despite legalization marijuana
trafficking and black market marijuana
continue to be in enforcement challenges
in both States and all states actually
who legalize treatment for marijuana use
in Colorado has decreased in suicide
incidents in which toxicology results
were positive for marijuana have in
increased I actually just someone sent
me an article today and in Colorado of
all the Teen suicides around 50% of um
white children is marijuana is in their
system Hispanic children it goes up a
little bit more and for black youth it's
actually 67% so
67% of people that kill themselves in as
teens in Colorado they test positive for
marijuana in the toxicology results
of note this bill would fund a new
position to provide statistics on the
effects of legalization in New Hampshire
and according to the Department of
Safety the requirements of this position
and the current lack of agency data
being collected now makes this a very
underfunded task before it even Begins
the lack of resource allocation and lack
of attention being paid to data
collection communicates The Reckless and
shortsighted approach that we're taking
towards legalization I'd like to Echo
what rep kahill said we're putting the
cart before the horse in so many
ways this funded position is merely a
rubber stamp inclusion to give the
impression that we are actually serious
about analyzing data and looking at
harms that would happen as a result of
legalization data from legalized States
has clearly shown that recreational
legalization does not live up to any
promises it will not make a safer
product for the market it will result in
higher addiction rates it will not in
any way help fund adequate addiction
treatment programs it will cause a
mental ill more mental illness in our
teens despite the fact that they can't
legally purchase it because it floods
the market in the state with more
available marijuana that they have
access
to and this will not amarate any social
justice issues and most likely result in
more
Injustice also um vulnerable minority
and economically challenged communities
will continue to be significantly
negatively impacted by
legalization in addition to in addition
to all this legalization does not
decrease the black market I actually uh
work for the Department of Emergency
Management Oklahoma I used to live there
so I work remotely for them this is
something they deal with Oklahoma is a
state that had uh they did just medical
marijuana they just recently resounded
shot down recreational
legalization um Oklahoma is actually
having a problem where they have uh
they're supplying the country with the
largest amount of black uh Market
marijuana and it's something that their
attorney general trying to get a handle
on and um much like Maine which I'll
touch upon in a minute uh
trans uh excuse me Criminal
organizations are just taking advantage
of the grow laws
there uh one of the things according to
the data compiled by the record Center
of alcohol and substance use studies
which is a multidisiplinary Institute
dedicated to addiction research
education training the black market in
color in California is thriving despite
the promises made by legalization as a
matter of fact fact the Black Market has
actually eclipsed the legal market and
why is that because the black market
will always beat your
price uh Colorado Oregon and Washington
State are Al all also finding out that
the black market continues to remain a
problem for them currently our neighbors
in Maine are dealing with hundreds of
Black Market Farms operated IL legally
by Asian transnational criminal
organizations which are flocking to the
state to Eng gratiate themselves in the
rural landscape we've got quite a bit of
rural landscape here in New Hampshire as
well uh worse yet this is an issue that
neither the US Department of Homeland
Security nor Maine's law enforcement
agencies can get a handle on it's
further worrisome that in addition in
addition to the negative Health outcomes
in the continuation of Black Market
influences states have legalized he a
marked increase in traffic deaths
involving drivers who tested positive
for marijuana in incidence of
DUI this means that even if a
responsible parent like myself I try to
do my best I have four kids you could
work years to raise your kids you could
try to do your best to keep them my
drugs particularly in a state that will
sell drugs to them the minute that they
turn 21 legally and they could still get
killed by somebody who's driving Under
the
Influence that as a parent that it
breaks my heart it really breaks my
heart and and we know in States IL
legalized that it's statistically is it
increases DUIs it's just
data so we have to ask ourselves
you know why are we doing this and we're
doing this because New Hampshire has a
spending problem and everyone's hoping
that this will be a Magic Bullet and
we're it's a it's a straw man argument
and all we're talking about is money
here that's what we're talking about all
of this we're all just keep talking
about money the reality is we're not
really having the conversations that we
need to have about our spending if
somebody actually really wanted to talk
about spending we'd really probably talk
about why why in our school systems our
administ rative cost going up teachers
going down and student populations going
down those are good conversations to
have um you know it's just a reality
that that quite frankly I heard in
previous testimony that we call this a
voluntary tax and we you know how great
it is that we have this I honestly it's
an addiction tax because the whole thing
is based off of how many people can we
get to smoke pot so that we can have
more money to spend on schools and
addiction
treatment and and I'd like to La lastly
I would like to address the reducing
harms um I would love to have a
conversation more about reducing harms I
think that could be a very bipartisan
wonderful conversation to have and if we
really want to look to reduce harms one
of the things that we would actually be
talking about is we would talk more in
these in these conversations about the
science of marijuana harms we would talk
more about the physi ological changes it
does to people like rep kill was saying
under 25 and Beyond we would talk about
how it increases psychosis in adults who
regularly use cannabis and more
importantly we would start actually
having bills about collecting data we
could actually have bills that that
mandate that hospitals can collect how
many people come through their doors
with cannabis use disorder those would
be wonderful and um and that that's
pretty much what what I'd like to say I
I guess I'd just like to leave you with
this thought what what price are are you
all willing to put on the mental and
physical health of our
youth and to be honestly the multitude
of new addicts that we're going to
create with legalization we can't
control the fact that it's that people
go over to Massachusetts or Vermont or
Maine to get to get their weed um we
just we just can't but but we could
actually decide to have some sanity in
that because we know based off data that
in every legalized State you will start
compromising the youth thank you for
your time yes ma'am well I'll the chair
I'm
sorry representative
buo thank you we take my question what
about liquor in the state can you
maybe a statement about liquor I
appreciate that but but sometimes when
we have these conversations people try
to make these moral equivalences today
we're we're hearing and we're talking
about HB
1633 and with all due respect I'd rather
not have a moral equivalent straw man
argument on what about liquor you were
just talking about schools further
question no I do have a question do you
have data from uh the 1970s because I
think there was a lot of marijuana use
you know back in the 70s 80s 9s this
isn't just like happening now because of
legalization in other states yes ma'am
and I I guess I would I would ask a
question back is do you have any data on
what's been going on with the THC levels
I mean I I did I actually read you the
data
um I don't have it from the 70s but I'll
I'll reread the data to you in case you
maybe didn't hear that average THC THC
levels in marijuana products has risen
from 3 to 23% in smokable marijuana and
56 to 99% in other forms marijuana is
actually being genetically modified to
have a THC punch that nobody in the 70s
could have ever imagined and as a result
we're seeing more psychosis more
addiction as a matter of fact Vermont
Vermont's medical um medical advisory
board recommended some measures to them
about two years ago stop advertising it
because they're seeing such a Negative
population they're having such an issue
with uh addiction and Vermont now has
the sad distinction of being one of the
highest states with the highest an uh
highest amount of addicted 13 to seven
year 17 year olds since
legalization I guess they're high
representative
Sullivan thank you so I I actually like
one of your ideas about harm reduction
in terms of maybe we can work together
to come up with some sort of Bill or
requirement for hospitals to keep track
of psychosis or whatever and and see if
we could I mean I think collecting data
will always inform us in the future for
making better bills and policies um on
the other thing that was a would you
believe and so my question
is I know you don't want to make the
moral equipment sleep I don't think it
is you said that we will always the
black m will always undercut marijuana
because it's always going to be cheaper
why doesn't that happen with alcohol why
does that not happen with tobacco is it
because it's still a fledgling industry
that is not legal federally that it's
not legal in every state I mean right
now we don't see a major Black Market
problem in alcohol or tobacco anywhere
that I'm aware of um I can't speak to
tobacco and I don't know the black
market statistics I I can't imagine that
I don't have any statistics Al that
doesn't exist well all I know is that
the black market now is it's cheaper to
grow when States put on their voluntary
tax their taxes whatever you want to say
whatever however you want to call it
quite frankly I mean the black market
just goes down I mean the reason that
the or black market just lowers their
price the reason that the Black Market
has eclipsed California legal Market is
because they're in a game of cat and
mouse with their tax rate and the I
think in the last legislative session
they were actually trying to lower their
tax rate of what they were gaining in
off of the top of marijuana products
because they were trying to compete with
the black market so I don't I don't have
an answer to your question of why we
don't see that I don't know Perhaps
Perhaps when prohibition was over and
you know there was a black market for
the alcohol industry I don't know all I
know is that that we have had over 10
years of data now in legalized States
and it doesn't get prettier and it
doesn't reduce the black market that's
all I know thank you representative
taxton have I have a question and
actually have two which leads to two
follow-ups it I understand from your
testimony that we are that Oklahoma and
Maine are net exporters of marijuana and
are they exporting to New Hampshire no
what I'm saying is there's Oklahoma
instituted grow policies for medical
marijuana uh they instituted LAX laws
the immediate thing that happened was
the green rush in Oklahoma where actual
um legal farmers who applied to these to
have some of these licenses came in but
also one of the things that flooded the
market is cartels there's uh Eastern
European Chinese and Mexican cartels
actually that came into Oklahoma and
they are they're have Farms that they're
running they did they they're not legal
Farms they're unlicensed Farms they're
flooding the black market so Oklahoma is
not supplying the the product here
Oklahoma's laws were for growing it in
their own state but but somehow just
like Maine is seeing somehow their rural
landscape made them prime target for
under thewire illegal markets so
Oklahoma is supplying is one of the the
Black Market Oklahoma is supplying the
majority of U pot in the US right now so
they are exporting to New Hampshire
further well the illegal the illegal
Market is she's entitled to her opinion
no I'm just no it's not it's it's not
opinion I I mean that's fine I mean okay
then you could then I believe me if you
don't want to believe me then by all
means refer to the information that the
Oklahoma attorney general puts out right
okay okay that exactly just I think I'm
good just representative
Gibbs thank you and thank you for taking
my question uh and I'm afraid this is
another would you believe uh in regard
to Black Market uh um in marijuana in
marijuana legalization States and that
is that there are states and New York
state is the example that I'm really
familiar with where marijuana was
theoretically legalized but the process
for obtaining a license to sell legal
marijuana was made so incredibly
complicated and bureaucratic that it
became essentially impossible to get
that license and as a result there are
practically no uh there have been
practically no uh legal Manana of
dealers and the Black Market has
thrived well I I would just say back
it's no surprise to me that the the
government of New York found another way
to screw something else
up yep
sorry well
representative MCU you have a question
thank Mr chairman thanks for bringing
this information um I I did forgive me
that because I did miss 639 I joined the
committee here Midway through uh so I'm
learning a few things watching some old
hearings and and whatnot
um but I have a bit of a background in
some of this so I'm so I'm pretty
familiar um my question for you is you
may know oh your microphone's you you
may know of and it wasn't the chairman
you may know of yeah you you may know of
some peer-reviewed published data
published in highle journals that can
talk to us about the other costs
associated with imp implementing
widespread recreational marijuana use
from other States since there's 10 years
of data now can you educate us a little
bit or maybe sorry if it's just me I
hope it's not just me can you educate us
on what are some of the other costs that
offset the tax earnings I would be happy
to share with you some of the data that
I presented uh last year I believe it
was in this committee or it might have
been the year before um it it talked
about actually Canada's state run model
and what happened with them uh as far as
the US for the US I'll see if I can find
some but I'll I'll send you the
information that I have but but maybe
you could maybe when I email you you can
be a little more specific about where
you're looking
for would that be all right okay that'd
be great
representative spear
oh thank
you I'm sorry but it would you believe
wait who are you asking the question to
I guess him no then they can't do it
thank you thank you very much thank you
sir
Tes
okay uh Devin chaffy from the
ACLU
does that work oh this a little loud
good afternoon chairman hun other
honorable members of the committee uh
for the record my name is Devon chaffy
and I'm the executive director of the
ACLU of New Hampshire um and it will not
surprise you that I'm here today to
testify in favor of HB 13 I mean
1633 um and I have to say I give a lot
of thought about how I should focus my
remarks today um you know I I thought at
first I could focus on
uh well first of all I've been working
on U marijuana legalization at the state
house for over a decade now as many of
you have been um and someone from our
organization has no doubt been here
before you to testify I'm sure on this
very issue many many times and so I
thought you know I could focus on the
question of why why do we need to
legalize and I could talk about how
marijuana arrests and convictions
needlessly ruin lives how the war on
marijuana is a Monumental waste of
taxpayer dollars or how the public
support in New Hampshire for
legalization is just
overwhelming um but I think you all know
that you've heard our testimony before
it'll be in my written testimony that
I'll distribute um I'm also happy to
provide you with some additional data
many studies that show that traffic
fatalities do not in fact go up in
states that have legalized the fact that
youth use does not in fact go up in
states that have legalized Etc I'll
distribute that to the committee in a
form of an FAQ um or I could get into
the details of this particular Bill the
good and the bad the strengths and the
weaknesses or other alternative
approaches um but what I really want to
focus on today and I have to say I do
not know that I have ever before so
emphatically agreed with the chair of
this committee but what I want to say
today is that we have a very narrow
window this year to actually make
legalization
happen for the first time in a decade
the entire time I have been in New
Hampshire we finally have a governor
that has said publicly that he will sign
marijuana
legalization into law we have bipartisan
support and both both the house and the
Senate we can actually see a real path
to
legalization this is a golden
opportunity right now and it is fleeting
we do not know what will happen when the
next Governor is
elected we need to come together this
year to get this
done so many members of this house so
many of you members that un fortunately
are no longer with us have spent hours
and hours trying to get this right over
the years we owe it to you we owe it to
them we owe it to that work not to miss
this
opportunity it's not going to be easy I
know that you all know that you know how
hard it is to make the sausage you're
involved in this every
day there's going to have to be
compromises from all sides I can tell
you that we at the AC Ste you we're not
going to get everything that we want
from this bill I know that going
in the industry is not going to get
everything that it wants neither party
is going to be fully happy with the
result the end product is not going to
be the perfect Bill there will have to
be cleanup that happens in subsequent
years but we have to get it
done it's beyond time every year that
passes is Revenue that New Hampshire has
just gifted to Massachusetts and to
Maine its taxpayer was money wasted on
unjust enforcement its lives ruined it's
needless it's time to be practical it's
time to put partisan politics aside and
it is time to come together and to
compromise and to really get this done
and I personally myself very much
looking look forward to working with any
and all of you over the coming months to
get marijuana legalization past the
Finish Line this year thank you so much
for your work on this issue and thank
you so much for your
time uh thank you and it's so nice to
know that the ACLU actually agrees with
me thank you very much thank you
chairman oh we do have oh we do okay I
didn't think
first thank you for testifying to our
committee um I just have a question
since we have you here about uh the the
use of marijuana in in in the state
prisons uh if you have any data or or
use on that and the reason I ask is
because that is that is a population
that is completely controlled uh and
locked down and uh if it's difficult to
keep drugs out of that environment then
in a free soci it's that much more
difficult to prevent people from using
it so I thought I'd ask you that
question and if you have any data on
that uh thank you representative I I
don't have any data on that specifically
I can certainly see in this state and
and I'll see if I can get any data on
that thank you okay representating M
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question what other drugs does the
ACLU support full legalization or
decriminalization or recreational use
for um list them yeah no there is no
other drug for which we are supporting
currently supporting full
legalization representative thank you
thank
you okay I mean there is no other
currently criminalized dropcast thank
you uh Bob Dunn from the Roman Catholic
bishop of
Manchester I was just thinking this
morning when I walked up and I saw you
sitting on the second floor that I
haven't seen Bob in a while
well we'll see if you're happy to see me
I I of course I know what your your
answer to this question is it's not
going to change from last year correct
right uh thank you Mr chairman and it is
good to be back um I don't get in front
of the Commerce Committee all that often
so I appreciate the opportunity to be
here uh I'm Bob Dunn the director of
public policy for the Roman Catholic
dasis of Manchester and I'm here today
on behalf of Bishop Peter labashi to
once again register our opposition to
the legalization of marijuana so we're
opposed to House Bill 1633 but we're
opposed to all of the legalization bills
so there's nothing unique about
1633 um and our reason for doing that as
always is because we think it runs
counter to the principle of the common
good and you've already heard reference
and I'd want CE again draw your
attention to the information that's in
the fiscal note or the the responses to
the fiscal note from the Department of
Safety and from the Department of Health
and Human
Services um and the the what the
assumptions are that they're making
about what the impact would be on life
in New Hampshire if we were to uh take
this next step so I'll uh simply ask uh
because I know you have a lot of people
to speak today um to think about four
questions um we posed these last year
will the passage of this law protect
Youth and improve family life will the
passage of the law improve public health
will the passage of the law improve our
communities and will the passage of this
law make people better workers and
strengthen our business
Workforce so we just ask you to keep
those in mind as you deliberate over
this legislation and any other similar
types of bills that may come forward
thank
you
Bob okay Switching over the other side
uh Dr Riley
Kirk go P five no okay
hi
hello thank you chairman Hart and the
other members of the committee today my
name is Dr Riley Kirk I have a PhD in
pharmaceutical sciences and I specialize
in the chemistry and pharmacology of
cannabis I also hold a USDA hemp license
here in New Hampshire today I'm speaking
in support of HB 1633 as I was also in
support of HB 639 proposed last year I
believe this bill will provide cannabis
consumers in New Hampshire access to
Safe affordable and accessible cannabis
products with lower tax rates compared
to neighboring states and the rest of
the legal Market this bill encourages
the support and erection of small
businesses which is a core value here in
New Hampshire and should be maintained
in this emerging industry hb6 1633 will
allow medical patients the right to
homeg grow their medicine it will allow
additional funding for education and
cannabis and Beyond lower property taxes
for New Hampshire residents encourages
and supports New Hampshire farmers and
probably most importantly prevents the
ongoing discrimination of people who
choose to use natural products this bill
emphasizes the importance of continued
research and
education and as a research scientist
this is very important to me and our
community this includes education
materials and resources within the
dispensary available on social media and
through other traditional media Outlets
education is the best form of harm
reduction and that is emphasized in this
proposed bill this bill has funds
allocated to Grants dedicated to the
research and development of cannabis
cannabis technology and cannabis
consumers to allow New Hampshire to be a
leading state in the field and be an
example for other states further funds
are to be allocated towards substance
use prevention and Recovery funds and
roadside testing via law
enforcement this bill also emphasizes
the importance of local politics
allowing each municipality to have final
say whether they participate and to what
degree this bill emphasizes the
effective tools used by other states to
Halt access of underage users including
stores being 1,000 ft from schools
childsafe packaging that even I have
trouble getting into sometimes and no
marketing towards children via the use
of cartoons or animals on packaging
materials there's no potency limit
proposed in this bill because of the
typically arbitrary numbers that are
associated in bills like this about THC
percentage and potency and potency is
often a proxy for Purity in many cases a
reminder that the FDA approved drug
called Marinol which is pure THC is 100%
THC and it's a pure drug and it's it's
shown High efficacy and safety for
patients that need it further this bill
will allow for residents of New
Hampshire and visitors of New Hampshire
to have safe access to cannabis to limit
the currently astronom ically High
number of drivers heading to Maine
Vermont and Massachusetts to purchase
cannabis via legal Avenues I don't know
if anybody's been to St Johnsbury bethl
or any sort of neighboring town in
Massachusetts but the parking lots are
full of New Hampshire plates mine
included
sometimes this will also limit the
impact of the illicit Market to again
ensure safe access to cannabis and
tested products our current
infrastructure is not stopping people
from using cannabis it is limiting the
access to Safe
products it is time for us to legalize
cannabis in New Hampshire and this bill
is the best proposed option to date to
support Farmers industry professionals
medical patients adult use consumers and
residents of New Hampshire I have
personally seen my friends and
colleagues in the Cannabis industry
apprehensively leave this great state to
go work in the surrounding states that
supported them their community and their
medicine we can't keep encouraging
skilled Farmers extractors and
manufacturers to choose between their
home state that they love and the plant
that has saved them I will end this
statement um emphasizing the safety of
cannabis and cannabis products and
reiterating the recent release from the
FDA showing that they encourage
rescheduling of cannabis to a schedule
three drug because of its safety
profile almost all pharmaceutical
medications have greater side effects
than cannabis and most importantly this
is a plant a living plant that has the
potential to heal a substantial amount
of condition
a plant with thousands of peer-reviewed
Publications unveiling the unique
chemistry and pharmacology and a plant
whose current legal status is rooted in
racism and discrimination as exemplified
earlier today with the Mexican and
Chinese cartels mentioned I strongly
believe that is a right to have access
to Nature and natural products and we
are doing a disservice to humanity and
the residents of New Hampshire by
limiting access to this ancient medicine
as a scientist and an advocate I believe
this bill is the best way our state can
move forward to join the majority of the
nation and creating a booming and
profitable cannabis industry in New
Hampshire I believe 1633 still allows a
significant amount of State control but
maintains the culture expertise and
Trust within the Cannabis industry thank
you for listening to my statement and
I'll take any and all
questions so um I just made a promise
that we'll be out of here by 5
o'l so let's make sure we're conscious
of
that representative MCU you have a short
brief question certainly less than an
hour and two minutes of questions no
that I got a dozen cards here thank you
Mr chairman thank you very much for
bringing your expertise and I'm really
interested in some of it um are you um a
farm a working pharmacist farm D or is
PhD in pharmaceutical science totally
different no I work on the um drug
Discovery side not the pushing drug drug
say got it but so you mentioned that
you're a a user you said you you you
shop at at there yep I'm a daily
cannabis user further question daily
cannabis user okay um so my my question
is since you're really knowledgeable
about all the different ways that
cannabis can be used for things like
anxiety Sleep Disorders you got it pain
management Etc question the question is
similar drugs that are used for those
same indications like say lorazapam
Xanax esone Lunesta ambient for Sleep
oxycodon trol etc for any the benzos or
any of the narcotics for
pain why don't we make those available
in the same stores because like you
mentioned Marinol is pure studied
regulated you know we know what's in it
then you also mentioned there's
thousands of varieties and got it we got
the question so why not take the Lunas
and things Lunesta tramol benzos put
them in the same stores same indications
I think aot and let the text hand them
out I think a lot of this comes down to
just a segregation in our beliefs of
medicine where a lot of people don't
believe or don't want to use
pharmaceutical type medicine they prefer
natural products like the cannabis plant
so it is you know segregated in that way
and I also wanted to bring up earlier
when you mentioned having MDS or what is
the requirement of the workers in
dispensaries often times as Tim Egan
mentioned yes it is required for them to
pass some sort of exam or test but
additionally we really shouldn't be
looking for MDS being part of this
because they are not taught about the
endocannabinoid system which is how
cannabis interacts with your body in
medical school rather we should be
looking at maybe the farm D's or the PHD
scientists or maybe other people have
just taken courses in this I have
personally dedicated a lot of my time
volunteering in main dispensaries to
help educate consumers and another thing
to mention here is our community in the
Cannabis industry we're passionate about
helping people we want to help teach
people and people want to learn so often
times the bud tenders at the dispensary
are people who have used thousands
hundreds of cannabis products and they
are experts in our industry people don't
become Bud tenders unless this medicine
has changed their life in some sort of
profound way and they have an integral
um connection with the community and
they talk with lived experience from so
many different people so for a
recreational Market they are the EXP
experts in recommending products and for
medical patients which I think we have
separated here medical patients there's
often resources to meet with a farm D in
a closed room for an hour or a half hour
there's many events that encourage the
intersection of traditional medicine and
and pharmaceutical medicine to make sure
that patients feel comfortable getting
this medicine at the right
dose thank you you use for yourself no
no no you asked your question you got
your question you got your question in
okay thank you very much thank you now
are you girls sisters yes okay so
Marissa and K Kaye yeah we have separate
testimon okay so whoever comes up first
is fine which one are
you thank you for the opportunity to
speak thank you representative hunt um
I'm Kaye mcglen a first year student at
Southern New Hampshire University in
process of two bachelor's degrees one in
science for criminal justice with
pre-law and one of arts and psychology
with addiction Sciences I'm here today
to R mind you of all the criminal
justice professionals you're
representing
today while I've exited the youth stage
I now dedicate my studies and theories
around the growing resources and time we
put into strengthening the men and women
of our Criminal Justice System
protecting the hardworking admirable
citizens of New
Hampshire I'd like to direct your focal
point to the today to the lack of
materials focused on this consumer
product of a scheduled substance like
marijuana I would hate personally to be
advocating and supporting for our local
state and federal criminal justice
professionals but then virtually
equipping them with nothing to prove
beyond a shadow of a doubt that someone
is guilty of an
offense I'm one of the youngest enrolled
students at Southern New Hampshire
University but I comment I heard from
one of my fellow students really
frightened me she said I drive so much
better when I am stoned than when I am
drunk I drive so much better when I am
stoned than when I am
drunk that's still a DUI offense
representative
P still a criminal
offense the perception of this so-called
plant is far beyond anyone's control to
reshape and fully encapsulate the nature
of this drug so that meaning if it's
just a little bit of weed you should be
fine to get behind the
wheel but what happens if you're pulled
over late at night by local municipality
for failure to maintain Lane control or
exhibiting intoxicated Behavior well the
officer May detain you based on the
presence of smell of marijuana coming
off a vehicle and notice clinical signs
such as blurred perception and red staky
eyes after speaking with many law
professionals this makes the criminal
justice system harder because there is
no field sobriety test for the drug
something so simple as a blood alcohol
content used in alcohol intoxication is
not available relying on the
professional to prove without well-
tested and trusted technology that the
individual based on law enforcement's
perception is under the influence of
marijuana and while we have some of the
most well-versed caring and qualified
men and women of law enforcement on our
front lines would that be something we
would have to burden them with even more
this often creates issues of lack of
proof in the courtroom when really we
cannot equip them with the technology to
properly execute their Duty we already
hear stories of intoxicated driving of
marijuana combined with other substances
on the RVE I don't have to State them
for you to know them it is important
that it is our responsibility to protect
and amend a better life for all Granite
Staters including our law en enforcement
professionals drunk stoned buzzed High
the matter of fact is that you're under
the influence of a substance and you
could be struck by an individual at any
time on the New Hampshire highway I
thank you for listening and I hope you
will join me and many others in the
opposition of hb1 1633 happy to take any
questions thank you very
much testimony testimony yeah your
written testimony can we get a copy that
would be
great uh Michael lean
leer sorry I didn't see you about
picking up your kid on Hope
oh I didn't see that
part start this uh Mr chairman members
of of the committee thank you for having
me my name is Michael Lon um I'm a
pharmacologist by
training I apologize to the committee I
walked in late today I went down to the
Judiciary Committee meeting I had just
read the committee report I don't know
how many of you read the committee
report it should be an embarrassment to
the entire house what was read it looks
like it's written by
prohibitionists it is absolutely amazing
our governor suggested a state run
store isn't the whole idea of this bill
to get government out of the way not to
grow government if people want how many
people had coffee this morning think you
don't have to answer if you had coffee
this morning you had caffeine I'm going
to come back to that we've heard about
addiction I'm going to come back to that
how many of you have had beer or prefer
wine my wife loves wine I like beer we
don't really mix to too um I've been
amazed the committee report I read and
looking at this bill
take the word marijuana out of that
committee report and put any other drug
or product in there and tell me you'd
want to open a store after reading
that how could anyone want to open a
store after reading that report it's
terrifying and as far as education
people have been telling kids that
marijuana is bad for I'm 53 years old I
don't ever remember being told otherwise
marijuana's bad I I think on South Park
right
okay you know what I'm talking about um
so that's how I got here I got
sidetracked how did we get here today
with prohibition if you look at the New
Hampshire Constitution Article three it
is very very explicit imagine marijuana
was not prohibited today if you looked
at that could you in good conscience
prohibit others from using marijuana
today and if so under what are you going
to offer up for that can you you name a
single Community here where the average
person couldn't go find marijuana
probably in under an
hour I'm not a regular user don't hold
it against me um I just I
find the the threats of we have all the
threats may not be the right word
there's fearmongering though we've heard
about addiction has anyone actually read
a study about the addictive properties
of
marijuana well let me tell you what some
of the qualities of ADD are you can have
a change in mood you can have a change
in appetite you can have a change in
sleep habits these tend to last about a
week ironically and I'm going to get
myself in trouble here if you look at
the side effects if I can call them that
of menstration they're about the
same are we going to make being a woman
illegal now I'm not Kidd look these up
I'm not
exaggerating these are what people tell
you are signs of addiction
I said I'd come back to Coffee anyone
know what the habits are coffee is
addictive what happens if you quit
coffee yet there are signs we can go the
whole way back to 1500 there was a guy
named paracelsus he's one of the
Godfathers of Toxicology he made a very
short statement dose makes the
poison with still true today we've heard
from someone marijuana potency has gone
up you know what they've gotten seeds
out of marijuana 2o I don't know how
many of you were fans of chich and Chong
when you were kids I thought those
movies were pretty darn funny apparently
people don't like smoking seeds
surprisingly it's not around today um
consumers a free market are going to
figure out what they want trying to
limit the
potency that we saw in this committee
report I think is absolutely asinine if
we're going to talk about harm reduction
for
real imagine you have something that's
10% THC you have something that's 30%
the person who wants to get high has to
use three times more product and the
major way that marijuana is used is
smoked the less you smoke the less risk
you have of developing other untour
medical conditions can also be consumed
by eating it there's other ways to
actually consume U marijuana there are
side effects there there's no question a
lot of that comes from the actual
smoking the concentrates that are out
there that people use in all kinds of
different devices now if you look and
see what's out there are absolutely
amazing I don't know what they need any
more than anyone knows what I like in my
coffee marijuana and coffee cannabis and
caffeine are a whole lot
alike I I don't know what else I can say
to this committee but marijuana I if we
want to encourage our kids to not use
the drug I have three boys I don't want
any of them stepping out and starting to
use marijuana the oldest is only 11
right now I've talked with them about it
I people talk about public education six
out of 10 students in New Hampshire
leave the 8th grade and cannot perform
math at grade level and you're going to
educate them about drugs you want to
talk about the PK and the pharmacology
and toxicology of marijuana anytime good
luck teaching that with a kid um I'm
100% in favor of this bill is written
and happy to take questions thank you
for your time uh thank you very
much okay chair we'll call on Marissa
mlin
good afternoon Mr
chairman hello everyone I'm Marissa
mcglen a freshman in high school and a
youth action member in the Raymond
Coalition for youth I want to offer you
a modern-day High schooler's
perspective I the 14-year-old student
who has offered a marijuana Vape in the
girls restroom last week the girl who us
to Elbow her way passed to visibly high
students just to wash her hands the
student who is saddened to see her
faculty overrun by teen marijuana use
and the future professional who fears
for the safety of her
state in 20122 a survey of 10,000 New
Hampshire adolescents ages 12 to 17
found that 80% had recreationally used
marijuana in the last in the past month
this study was conducted while
recreational marijuana is legal in New
Hampshire and it shows that a large
amount of juveniles have already found
ways to get
marijuana if this bill were to be passed
it would only make it easier for teens
to obtain the drug making teenage
marijuana use
Skyrocket I cannot begin to imagine the
impact that increased access could have
to the Adolescence in my community how
many kids will be in the restroom using
marijuana how many more will be high in
class what would this look like long
term for my generation statistics have
broached these questions already are we
listening I find it rather difficult to
even fathom all the consequences that
this bill carries with it and the
generation being most effective ected by
it will also be the generation running
this country in future
years this is a large concern to me
knowing one in six adolescents Who start
using marijuana before the age of 18
will develop marijuana use disorder the
inability to stop its use despite the
negative effects on their lives meaning
addiction New Hampshire has to do its
best to protect its Youth and Future
Leaders of this country I ask you all to
put aside any perceived profits or
returns that you feel Maybe gained by
passing this bill but instead consider
the cost and damage it will cause our
youth because I doubt it is a price you
were willing to pay thank you for all
your time and consideration I'm willing
to answer any and all
questions I think we're all questioned
out thank you very much perfect thank
you thank you I have your written
testimony would be great Okay Ross
sorry I know you always told me I should
put you a higher up on the list but oh
it's
so
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee it is always great to be back
in in house Commerce here in New
Hampshire uh for the record my name is
Ross Connelly I'm the northeast regional
director for Americans for Prosperity
here to voice our wholehearted support
for HB
1633 um I just I'll be brief I I'll
touch on some of the the things that
were discussed um you know this bill we
think is the best path forward uh we
think having a free market system is the
absolute best way to to block block out
uh the black market uh eventually it
takes time to do that uh as has been
pointed out in previous testimony um but
this bill does address our our three big
pillars which is uh keeping licensing
fees low allowing every uh average
Granite Staters to enter the market uh
to drive down cost uh also having uh
robust uh regulations to make sure that
it's a safe product for consumers uh and
then minimal taxation to make sure that
we're we're competitive and also uh
probably most importantly making sure
that uh that in a legal regulated system
that miners cannot access it and makes
it very very very difficult for them to
access it
um I have the the uh you could look at
as a benefit or a negative uh ability I
I've been working in uh the rest of the
New England states over the past year uh
and uh as as we know we are surrounded
by these states that have decided to to
legalize cannabis
um they know the position that we're in
I I'll just say I've had discussions in
in down in Boston with with
Massachusetts legislators about this
topic and how uh I hope that New
Hampshire makes the the decision to to
move forward and legalize cannabis and
their response is New Hampshire will
never do it we make make the decisions
for them I think it's time for New
Hampshire to make this decision uh and
and I know this bill will be worked on
going forward um and and we're we're
here to to be part of that process to
make sure that we can find a bill that
has a path to pass the Senate be signed
by the governor um but we we we need to
do it as soon as possible because the
the the status quo that we're in where
we're exporting decision making to other
States and then our citizens are
bringing back this those products that
we don't know what the testing
requirements might be uh in Maine
compared to Massachusetts new New
Hampshire should have the say in how we
set up our our our market and we should
get the benefits and we should have uh
the oversight of of this this industry
because as it stands now any of the the
uh arguments that if we legalize this
will happen or that will happen uh we
would already be seeing that in uh in
the state because anybody just go down
to Massachusetts a little anecdote I
went down Black Friday shopping the the
Pheasant Lane Mall right next to the
Pheasant Lane Mall right over the Border
uh it's it's called Nature's remedy it's
a a legal uh recreational uh cannabis
store in Massachusetts the line was so
long for their Black Friday sale that it
went into New
Hampshire and this the police in New
Hampshire were having direct to to
direct traffic for a cannabis store in
Massachusetts that's totally absurd and
it's time that we we fix that uh and I
just will mention we do have concerns
you know where it goes to to large State
models you know we voiced these concerns
before we want to make sure that uh
there there is a supply uh that's that's
built up so that we're lowering costs
and we're competitive with neighbors uh
so that's a concern it when it comes to
uh like a franchise type model I would
just caution I I think some folks
mentioned uh different Federal uh
implications there but one complaint on
a franchise to the federal uh Federal
Trade Commission uh could be be uh an
issue for the state and I mentioned
before on on a a completely state-run
model you know putting a New Hampshire
pension system at risk uh because state
employees are selling a federally
illicit product
uh is a concern but like I said we we
have never opposed a a a cannabis bill
at Americans for Prosperity as far as uh
I'm here uh we won't uh we want to be
part of the process to to make sure we
find this path forward uh this coming
year so uh I'd be happy to take any
questions okay thanks thank you very
much okay
fry
from new Futures in opposition to the
bill yeah
yeah
good afternoon members of the committee
I know it's been a long afternoon I will
try to be very brief you are getting my
written testimony as well as a side by
side with our Prince new Futures
principles why I'm glad others are
presenting a comparison to you I would
rather do that since I'm from New
futures um and you'll also get a copy of
uh the quack back report who um does
follow a state model so um again my name
is Kate fry I'm the vice president of
advocacy at new Futures we're nonprofit
nonpartisan organization that works on
health and wellness policies um and we
work closely with policy makers
stakeholders prevention Partners to
prevent reduce alcohol and drug problems
in our state so we here at new Futures
believe that it is imperative get
cannabis commercialization policy right
from the start optimal policy from our
state must best utilize the best
available scientific evidence to reduce
Public Health harm limit Youth and
problematic use and purposely Advance
social justice and Equity that's why
we've created our principles for
cannabis policy and regulation guide and
um we track how it each bill aligns with
these principles um so as you have in
the document they principles include
protecting Children and Youth promoting
social justice jce and opportunities for
Equity protecting public health and
ensuring appropriate funding for
cannabis re uh Revenue directed to
reduce
harms again you will have our testimony
that um does a side by side while again
I appreciate others interpreting what
our uh principles are and how they align
I'll do that very quickly um I will say
I'm protecting Children and Youth um
there were previous versions of the bill
that were actually stronger in this area
than House Bill 633 um it does not have
potency limits we feel strongly there
needs to be potency limits based on um
the evidence of uh addiction increases
and increases in um psychosis based on
high potency products um we hear a lot
that it's a plant it's a highly
engineered plant and um potency limits
have been adopted in other states we
would um ask New Hampshire to do the
same um there is an Advisory board that
just makes recommendations but there's
nothing in the statute that requires it
to happen um they have this bill has
weaker regulations on prohibitions
around advertising and marketing than I
think the last bill considered by um
this committee um for example it include
it doesn't include a clear prohibition
on marketing to minor specifically
related uh to social media I also have
put in language in the last Square so
you have amended language uh we offered
you amended language um also it does not
require the standard recognizable symbol
for cannabis um advertising the language
is May as opposed to Shell and it does
not include a Prohibition for billboard
advertising which is the case with
alcohol advertising um the buffer zone
piece of it it excludes preschools so it
requires Elementary and secondary
schools to be within that th000 ft but
not preschool schol previous uh versions
have pre uh preschools we would also um
ask that uh what be included based on
the,
1400% increase in cannabis um poisonings
uh be addressed through requiring
cannabis retail stores to sell
medication lock boxes um just sell them
people don't have to buy them they're
just sold it's the safest way to keep
your cannabis um safe from um kids and
other
individuals um in the promoting social
justice and Equity while there's an En
nment process there isn't anything that
provides economic opportunities for
those communities impacted on the war
and drugs well there's a Community
reinvestment Fund it's not the
originally intendent Justice investment
fund that many supporters had um
supported in the original vot and then
lastly on the revenue piece I am not a
math uh whiz at all but um I will say
that uh the funding for the Substance
Abuse Prevention Recovery Fund while I'm
very thankful there is that fund of
which 10% is she be allocated it looks
like
120% prior to that 10% is going to
pensions education and the involment F
investment fund so I'm not exactly sure
how 120% can go to other areas and there
would be any funding left over for
substance use prevention and recovery so
I would ask somebody to look at the math
again I'm not a math Wiz um and then
lastly we just want to make sure that we
have that New Hampshire has an
opportunity to approach the most
responsible model of cannabis
commercialization for its residents the
data suggests that one of the best
examples of safer commercialization is
in Quebec which utiliz its existing
public alcohol system to create an
exclusive providence province owned
cannabis ret sales system it operates
stores and collects Revenue but it
doesn't aggressively advertise cannabis
except where to get it legally and
strongly limits the types of products to
avoid the more dangerous High potency
concentrates and products that are
attractive to kids um it's had the same
trans High transition to the legal
Market as other provinces but with less
growth in conception and high public
satisfaction um and they've generated um
quite a bit money as well while keeping
the use of dangerous products um low in
their Province um so I've included
copies of that report um the study
committee did look at this model while
there was no final recommendation we
encourage this committee to look at
benefits of a state model as opposed to
the industry-driven private model in
front of you we urge the committee to
amend House Bill 6 1633 to meet new
Futures principles and create the best
model for the good of its residents not
the Cannabis industry we'd be happy to
provide the committee with language to
ensure all principles are included in
these bills I have included it in the
side by side as well but I'm happy to
provide other language if
needed representative Gibbs has a
question thank you Mr
chairman uh and I'm afraid this is
another would you believe um I'll make
it as quick as I can um uh would you
believe that the attempt to help those
who were negatively affected by
criminalization in the past is one of
the things that made the um New York
legalization process so complicated that
it was practically
impossible uh to get a license to uh
legally sell marijuana uh with the
result that the black market stayed in
effect and there were practically no
legal marijuana dealers I believe you're
talking about the maybe a licensing
approach that they took um that's not
the only way you can create economic
opportunities for those impacted by in
the War on Drugs you can create a funds
you can create um opportunities for
investment other opportunities like that
there was a Justice reinvestment Fund in
one previous version that um is more of
a fund that offers um opportunities to
people like job training um help with um
expungement um help with education um so
I wouldn't rule out one States bad
experience with licensing um and just
not do any um social justice um
Provisions in a bill just because of one
bill one State's experience thank you
represent Amon Mr chair thank you for
taking our questions um I'm just looking
at a a post on NHC can.org
and they say that this bill this
particular Bill 1633 meets 83% of the
new Futures requirements yeah I just
want to that's probably their estimate
83% yeah I was wondering my question is
uh what percentage or uh does this bill
meet uh a good majority of your
requirements and uh if not how so so
I've handed that out so in an area
that's red it doesn't meet the principle
in an area that's yellow it's somewhat
close but needs um amending and I've
offered language and green that's where
the principal is met I'm really happy
that the Cannabis Association is
concerned about our principles but no
one's contacted me to uh discuss those
and um uh really sit down and talk about
them and compare with our principles
maybe in their eyes they've met our
principal but I have specific language
that I can provide them that would get
them to grain so um I think it's all in
my side by side
thank you very
much uh Beth
skur hi I'm a mom from NASA and I'm here
to testify in opposition to
1633 I'll read a little bit from an
editorial from the Washington examiner
which you can read at bit. l/c Canabis
chaos the drug policy Alliance funded by
George Soros has been instrumental in
legalizing marijuana in 11 states in
Washington
DC the promised benefits of legalization
however have failed to materialize
leaving hundreds of communities with
more addiction death and Chaos contrary
to what propaganda at the drug policy
Alliance tell you marijuana is not a
benign substance with medicinal
properties marijuana is a addictive
particularly for young users its
habitual consumption is linked to
schizophrenia and permanent brain damage
particularly in the frontal
cortex as the strength of marijuana has
increased in recent years it has become
more addictive and more
damaging whenever the drug policy
Alliance succeeds there are more addicts
more brain damage more ruined families
what about the supposed benefits of
legalization is crime decreased now that
it's legal to buy sell and possess
marijuana are states that legalized
marijuana rolling in new tax revenues
are fewer people taking opioids and
Fentanyl now that marijuana is a legal
option the answers are no no and
no legalization has clearly increased
crime strict regulations and taxes
placed on legal sellers have created a
vast illicit Market that easily
undercuts the legal Market on price and
because possession is legal it is
virtually impossible to crack down down
on the illegal Market this has left
rural communities that never experienced
drug violence before vulnerable this has
brought drug related shootouts robberies
kidnappings and killings to communities
that never had them before with the
illegal Market roughly double the size
of the legal one estimated tax revenues
from legal marijuana s Sals have fallen
far short of expectations leaving States
stuck with massive bills for increased
drug addition addiction C services but
without the extra Revenue to pay for
them Recent research confirms
legalization is also associated with
higher opioid uis and M mortality
instead of acting as a substitute for
more harmful drugs legal marijuana is a
gateway to their increased
use the remaining State should learn to
push back
hard um I'm sorry cut that my brother
started smoking marijuana at a young age
speaking of data from the' 7s my brother
started smoking in the 70s and he
developed full-blown
schizophrenia I'm sure there's a lot of
other
people dealing with the after effects of
the 70s I I haven't had contact with him
since before my youngest was born 28
years ago we searched for him online and
found a mug shot from when he was
arrested for squatting on someone's
property he can't take care of himself
and he's been in and out of homeless
shelters for decades
a piece in tablet details the serious
mental health harm from marijuana you
can find it at bit. l/c Canabis dasp
paranoia and the key quote from it is
one out of every 20 daily users can
expect to develop schizophrenia if they
don't quit that's from Dr Christine mil
Miller an expert on psychotic disorders
please vote itl and HB 1633 to protect
our state from the serious harms from
the expansion of marijuana sales for
recreational
use thank you very much for your
testimony okay I got five cards left I
want to be out of here by five or
otherwise I'm a liar so I'll ask each of
you to try to be uh brief and try to say
something new and different that we
haven't heard
already okay all right Jim Riddle
first
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee um I'm sending around a a
handout but it's not a copy of my
written comments it's just some
background
material uh I live in Hillsboro uh New
Hampshire I have a USDA hemp grower
license I've been a farmer my entire
life I also serve on the advisory Board
of the New Hampshire cannabis
Association and last fall I led an
effort uh working with the Farm Bureau
and the Northeast organic Farmers
Association New Hampshire to survey
farmers in New Hampshire to see what
their position is on
legalization and 87% of The respondents
Who currently Farm support
legalization and 78% of those expressed
interest in becoming licensed Growers so
there is interest and there is support
amongst agricultural community and one
of the most surprising results was a
level of support for homegrown cannabis
the ability to grow a few plants 89% of
the respondents supported allowing uh
New Hampshire residents to grow six to
eight plants there wasn't was not strong
support for a state-run monopoly only
10% of New Hampshire Farmers supported
the state being the sole outlet for
cannabis products in New
Hampshire I also
attended all but the last two of the
Cannabis commission hearings
meetings and uh which was very
fascinating and it was really focused on
developing a bill around a franchise
model which did not get forwarded here
from the commission but there was a lot
of discussion of a com a franchise
system
and one thing I learned when the
Attorney General uh uh representative
spoke is a franchise system would not
protect the state from liability at all
because to have a franchise you had to
sell something you have to franchise
something of value so it would be a
state brand and the state would be
franchising the sale of New Hampshire
cannabis Outlet products and so if
someone is harmed at a franchise they're
not just going to stop by suing the
franchise no the state is the one that
owns that by being the
franchisor um the uh another problem was
that the structure of the the franchise
system The Liquor Commission would be
both the regulator and the marketer now
that's an inherent conflict of interests
that's a built-in uh conflict of
interest and franchises are controlled
by the Federal Trade Commission so this
is under Federal control so the state
would be stepping directly in to control
by the FTC over this and the fees that
were talked about were just exorbitant
around a million dollar to have a
franchise in certain locations around
the state and you may have missed that
uh meeting uh uh Mr chair but yes that
was you mean when I had Co well when
you're in Amsterdam um
but uh anyway the franchise model really
stifles free
enterprise um and it really it's not
going to stop the illicit market and I
hate people calling it The Black Market
please call it the illicit Market um it
doesn't do anything to help Granite
State farmers and uh I think we have a
much better model and the thing with yes
Quebec is running a state you know
Province but they're in a legal country
we're still in a federal
prohibition and uh um the uh bill that
is put before you
1633 um I think is the best way to go
yes there's some improvements that were
suggested today that should certainly be
taken into
consideration um but I've been spending
time lately in Vermont Maine and in
Minnesota uh and Minnesota just
legalized so they're still in the
process of of rolling out the rules but
there was question asked earlier about
sobriety test and they actually do have
a field sobriety test that they're in a
one-year validation process which is
what happened with a breathalyzer when
it was first rolled out it wasn't just
put right out there and you know rely on
the results it takes validation and so
right now there's a year of validation
going on in Minnesota so it's something
to look at uh as this uh takes effect
but the thing that's really struck me in
these states which have legalized is the
level of economic activity that's
happening I me people are excited young
people have a future they're talking
about science they're talking about
marketing they're talking about
packaging they're meeting one another
they're have all these different
conventions and events going on to share
information and I really think that
that's something that uh uh New
Hampshire could use um you know so I
really hope that this is the year we
move a bill all the way through the
house thank you very much and the Senate
needs to get on board and the governor
no the governor needs this is his legacy
his last chance let's put the best Bill
forward that the farmers support that's
based in free enterprise that's you know
follows our model that leads to a safe
tested regulated and taxed Market in the
livefree state
thank
you okay thank
you uh Dan
Allegre thank you chairman hunt my name
is Dan
Alig uh I'm here today as a member of
the public I have no pecuniary interest
in the Cannabis industry I have not been
prompted by anyone to be here I not
being paid by anyone to be here here my
testimony which I submitted
electronically is my own and unlike
representative kahill's suggestion I am
not
uninformed um the point has been made
made by opponents that there are
heartbreaking stories of cannabis abuse
lives ruined automobile accidents uh
medical
impacts all of which is is heartbreaking
and irrelevant because cannabis is here
the Point has been made it rolls across
our state border every hour of every day
every state and Province we border and
every state and Province they border
have authorized adult use sales and we
are not stopping every car at the border
and searching it it would destroy our
economy cannabis is here and what sets
us apart with our prohibition is that we
are unable to mitigate those impacts
with tax revenues that are being
collected from from our citizens every
purchase of cannabis out of state
includes a tax and it goes to another
state government to fund prohibition and
education and treatment and Public
Safety we are being
Chumps and it's time to change that and
this bill changes it a point that you
all know but it's worth mentioning
because no one has is that it polls by
more than two to one in favor and if
you're opposed that's a lot of
constituents to be ignoring
um it's a powerful message and one you
should think carefully about on the
question of an alternative model um I
don't envy you chairman hunt uh I hope
you find a way to get a bill done one
way or another but I will offer this as
food for thought I'd like to read one
sentence to you free and Fair
competition in the trades and industries
is an inherent and essential right of
the people and should be protected
against all monopolies and conspiracies
which tend to hinder or destroy it those
words have been in article 83 of our
state constitution since the year
1784 and I can't think of a more
authoritative or compelling statement of
why we should adopt a competitive
model lastly opponents of the bill will
try to pick it apart by pointing out
that there's an actual issue or problem
it doesn't solve well who's ever drafted
a perfect Bill the question is not how
does it compare to the ideal Bill the
question is how does it compare to the
status quo and I think this bill is a
vast Improvement and I think it's very
important that lawmakers not lose sight
of that I know it's late in the day I
thank you for your patience and
Indulgence in allowing me to present my
testimony I did submit it electronically
to the committee I have a few courtesy
copies if anyone needs one and I'm happy
to answer any questions that any members
may have for
me I think we're all set with questions
thank you I'll take a copy thank you
very much okay Nathaniel
Gan I don't
know thank
you good afternoon
uh chairman hunt members of the
committee thank you so you got five
minutes not 10 that's fine I'm I intend
to uh be succinct in respect for the
fact that we all want to get going um
I'm um speaking here this afternoon I'm
um the uh chair of the uh New Hampshire
cannabis party however I'm speaking here
this afternoon within the context of my
nine years of full-time professional
practice experience and expertise in the
rarified field of cannabis banking
electronic payments compliance and
related Financial Services um I'm going
to make one small um you know reference
with regard to the commission then I'm
going to get right to my main point um
uh except to say that um recently I did
complete a fair amount of study and
research on the topic of um DWI cannabis
related um testing both breath lizers
and blood tests and the rest of that and
should any um I'm not going to get into
it now it'll take a few minutes to talk
about but should any committee meter
member um you know ask me about that um
or wish to pursue that later I'll be
more than happy to get into that but I
could provide some expertise and
guidance on that
um the State Liquor Commission under the
leadership of commissioner Joe mikica
and his executive team have acquitted
themselves and their standout with their
standout professionalism energy and
Devotion to the state's best interests
although they knew little at first about
the Cannabis industry over the past 18
months they've become well informed by
learning from stakeholders visiting
licensed operations in other states
studying the relevant issues and nuances
and thoughtfully incorporating it all
into their proposal proposals in my
professional opinion they are already
best qualified in collaboration with a
well-chosen stakeholder advisory panel
to implement regulate and supervise our
cannabis industry they also understood
enough to know that state employees
cannot be required to engage in
violations of federal law so they
devised a workaround franchise model in
which the commission itself would not
actually sell cannabis but franchise
independent operators to do so with the
rationale that the state would then not
be required to defend those operators
from possible Federal enforcement
penalties and
consequences however I've seen
innumerable examples of these seemingly
clever industry workarounds over the
years and sooner or later they have all
collapsed usually ugly my main point and
leaving aside everything else is that
the current state Monopoly proposal is
reckless and Thoughtless and effectively
a non-starter and cannot actually be
implemented and I therefore urge this
committee to pass HR 1633 if it intends
to actually enable a a viable commercial
cannabis industry uh in New Hampshire
with the tension between federal and
state law the Cannabis industry is
complicated and chaotic in many often
unforeseen ways for example as somebody
alluded to here earlier the commission
as franchisor would be required to file
what is known as a franchise discloser
document with the Federal Trade
Commission subjecting them to Federal
jurisdiction penalties and
investigations
a criminal Enterprise cannot offer
franchises of its business model please
let that sink in contrived legal
firewalls notwithstanding the state
liquor commission's position would be
precarious and could easily become
subject to Serious anticipated and
unanticipated legal risks and
entanglements claiming to not be
directly involved in the business of
selling cannabis because one is merely a
franchise or is as Prima fascia absurd
as Donald's claiming it's not in the
business of selling hamburgers because
it has
franchisees the primary miscalculation
here is in not understanding the unique
and subtle challenges of the Cannabis
industry that has no modern equivalent
as a result of the tension between
states legalization and prevailing
Federal prohibition there are
innumerable loose ends and foreseeable
as well as unforeseeable consequences
that arise constantly to bevil even the
savviest industry pioneers and insiders
even as thoughtful in his experienced as
I and many of my colleagues are in this
field we are often blindsided by
unforeseen hiccups obstacles and
restrictions that subvert otherwise
well-considered plans our political
leaders are utterly ill equipped to
enact cannabis industry policies that
tread into such Uncharted Territory
beyond the narrow legal path charted by
other states that have implemented
sustainable cannabis
programs and to that point by the way
regarding the proposed cannabis Advisory
Board it would be counterproductive and
negligent to have the governor and
executive counsil appoint its members
since neither have any demonstrated
experience or expertise in identifying a
representative cross-section of
stakeholders um I recently had an
opportunity to chat with the governor um
uh on this topic uh as well as uh
cannabis Banking and some other stuff um
and his comments were interesting um he
uh basically told me that um it was
going to be the state mon model or
nothing um and I said well you can't do
that um and he said well yes I can and I
said no you can't and he said well um
only one of us standing here is the
governor and yes I can so I don't know
if that sounds like our governor but um
however um and and I and I do understand
how he could think that okay because
under ordinary circumstances that would
be the case but let me give you a couple
examples um the second largest uh
payroll uh service in the United States
is a company called paychecks uh they're
second only to ADP and about two or
three years ago they had a big trade
exhibit at a cannabis uh trade show and
they announced that they were now going
to extend their provide their services
to the Cannabis industry I pointed out
to them that it was certainly doable as
long as they followed a um clear and
delineated path of banking compliance
and other types of reporting that was a
feasible thing to do but um they needed
there was only one way to do that um and
we actually got to the point of where we
were in contract negotiations they were
going to engage my company to actually
put together the framework that would
allow them to do it legally and
compliantly however um you know
institutional egos prevailed and they
basically felt that hey you we're a big
multi-billion dollar company and we tell
our banks what to do and the banks don't
tell us what to do well three or four
months later they exited the Cannabis
space with their tail between their legs
because it doesn't matter how big you
are um there this is this is a very
tricky business and no matter how tough
you are it's you just can't do it um the
other quick example that I'll give you
is in the case of MasterCard Visa who
specifically and unequivocably prohibit
cannabis transactions on uh their
payment rails and there are lots of
people who have done all kinds of uh
workarounds uh a lot of my experience
with those that have failed are related
to that
um people come up with all kinds of
clever devices like well we'll use the
MasterCard visa to fund a virtual gift
card or virtual checking account or a
PayPal style ewallet or something along
those lines um and the problem is that
that all works very nicely until they
get the bad call from Visa which says
you can't do this um and they have all
to a man uh dozens and dozens of them
folded like a cheap suit
um in 2017 a federal district court in
Massachusetts dismissed a RICO case um I
have the citation against a bank on the
grounds that merely providing customary
Financial Services to a cannabis state
license C orbe it operating in violation
of federal law did not rise to the level
of Direction in and control of the
Enterprise to implicate Rico liability
as a code defendant this reasoning
allows States right now to regulate
cannabis industry operators as a
customary government function as long as
they are not substantially involved in
the operation and direction of the
business itself however the franchise
model proposed by The Liquor Commission
envisions quite the opposite as they
would be enforcing strict standards in
almost every aspect of franchise
operations directions and practices
enacting this scheme could easily invite
multiple Rico based private litigations
as well as public prosecution frankly a
hybrid State Monopoly commercial
cannabis business model with both
state-owned and private operators side
by side may be a pioneering and smart
option and perhaps should be ultimately
given some consideration but only
following the end of federal prohibition
requiring state employees to violate
current federal law is reckless and
Thoughtless and effectively a
non-starter meanwhile I have been in
contact with the Department of Justice
Office of legal policy for written
clarification of the risk of federal
investigation and prosecution
that this state Monopoly framework might
attract and hope to have something to
submit when the Senate takes this up in
the coming weeks I'm pausing again to
let I just want you to know we're you've
gone now 10 minutes okay and I have the
rest of this last sentence and I'll be
done okay because we have two more
people all right and I have we have to
be out here at five one sentence and
this is the most important one my
testimony here today is intended to
serve as a formal on the record public
notice to those who participate in
enacting the proposed state Monopoly
legislative time bomb that they are
exposing themselves individually and our
state to potentially crippling and
multiple criminal and civil penalties up
to and including Reco charges and the
federal seizure of commission and state
property and Pension funds thank you
thank you very much you're very welcome
you want to submit that uh I can if
you'd like yes we like
we want to have that in the file yeah
okay would you like me to just uh send
it electronically or just put in here if
you is that you give us what you have
that's I'll give you I'll give you what
I have Matt Simon you're up next you got
two
minutes you wrote two minutes I'm gonna
hold you to two
minutes thank you Mr chairman honorable
committee good to see you all again for
the record my name is Matt Simon I work
for granite Leaf cannabis uh if you
don't recognize the name of that company
we did change our name in September
forly Prime ATC we're still a small
nonprofit therapeutic cannabis company
uh with dispensaries and Chichester and
marac focus solely on serving patients
in New Hampshire very briefly this is a
good bill it takes the thoughtful
approach to adult use legalization I was
not involved in the drafting process for
the specific bill was part of the
Coalition that drafted the predecessor
Bill uh last fall I was busy dealing
with the study commission so I wasn't
weighing in on this draft legislation
but I'm pleased to see that it maintains
a lot of good policies I wanted to touch
on three of them very quickly one
thoughtful integration of the
therapeutic cannabis program this bill
is one example of how to do a good job
with that there are other ways that
could be done if there's going to be
another model that that is pursued but
that is an important priority this bill
does it well
this bill also clearly establishes The
Authority for the commission to regulate
hemp derived synthetic THC products uh
we heard that referenced by a couple
people who spoke earlier uh those
products are now illegal for at least
the next year under New Hampshire law uh
but they are still being sold uh in some
places so if those products are going to
be approved for sale they are inherently
more risky than natural cannabis they
should be sold through the same
regulated system I would argue finally I
love that this bill includes home
cultivation for registered patients and
caregivers hom grow is legal for adults
in every New England state if we're not
going to do that uh I believe we should
do uh let's passed the house 10 times
and the Senate four times which is allow
limited home cultivation for patients
and
caregivers so I think those are
important policy priorities whether it's
this bill or some other Bill and I'm
happy to hang out with the the sub
subcommittee and I'm happy to get out of
here before 5:00 p.m. thank you thank
you very much all right Austin what more
you're the last
guy and you
have I'll make it quick you wrote three
but I don't think you have three all
right I appreciate everyone letting me
come here chair U my name is Austin
whittamore I'll be speaking in support
of this bill the live free Bill I'm a US
Army veteran medically discharged with a
background in Nutrition dietetics a
master of science and nursing currently
working as an ICU nurse at the state's
only level one trauma and stroke Center
Dartmouth Health Dartmouth Health in
lebanan New Hampshire I conducted my
Mass's thesis project on the lack of
patient safety surrounding cannabis
related to its Federal status lack of
evidence practices and lack of Education
surrounding cannabis use I am now in the
next stages of my career as I compl
complete my certificate course in
cannabis nursing a profession recognized
to be one of the most for the last 21
years trusted professions in all of the
United
States I say this because as many of you
may not not know the scope of practice
of cannabis nursing was published and
recognized by the American Nurses
Association and the American cannabis
Nurse Association in September of last
year it is the first federally
recognized scope of practice related to
cannabis for healthc care professions
and serves to give nurses the ability to
act as advocates Educators and
Navigators to guide patients towards a
maximum state of homeostasis through the
upregulation of the endocannabinoid
system through the use of phyto
cannabinoids tpin and terpenoids found
in the cannabis
plant as we know from the accepted
therapeutic program in our state and
that fact that more than 75% of US
states have approved some Court of
medical cannabis program the fda's
current approval for derivatives and
isolates as other people have mentioned
such as Marinol for endog exogenous
cannabinoids in the recognition of the
Cannabis nursing by the Ana
evidence-based mechanisms of the ECS and
exogenous cannabinoids as well as the US
Department's Health and Human Services
descheduling recommendation that
prohibition on cannabis and not and was
never based on scientific research and
and evidence-based practices cannabis
was in the medical pharmacopia and
prescribed by doctors until the
marijuana Tax Act of 30 1937 was passed
which made cannabis Bamm to prescribe in
an attempt to discourage the practice as
big pharmaceutical companies began to
create patentable drugs to treat similar
medical disease States and symptoms
between this time in the late 20th
century several State officials
including the New York city mayor lag
Guardia and a couple US presidents to
include Nixon and Reagan form committees
to examine cannabis for Medical
Therapeutics and add addiction potential
two common themes came from these
committees unanimous support for medical
potential and low addiction SL abuse
potential yet Federal officials were
quick to call these findings
unscientific continuing the reer madness
and say no to drug campaigns the
domestic policy chief of Nixon John enel
richond even G out to reporters saying
that they criminalized marijuana was
easier to arrest and vilify minority
groups or as we better know as the bipo
population people black indigenous and
people of color and he added in quotes
did we know we were lying about drugs of
course we we did and this was the
conscious reaction to anti-government
anti-war organizations this stigma has
been maintained in our society greatly
affecting our citizens ability to access
safe Natural Herbal Remedies and
stigmatizing the use of a herb that was
once in the pH medical pharmacopia it is
also driven Injustice to our bipo
populations as they continue to face
National and Statewide racial
disparities related to cannabis based on
a 2018 summary from the American civil
liberties Union black individuals were
4.1 times more likely to be arrested for
cannabis possessions compared to whites
in the state of New Hampshire this is
higher than the 3.64 times of the
national average the United States
Department of Health and Human Services
states that stigma is considered to be
the most formidable obstacle to Future
progress in the area of mental illness
and health stigma has reduced the
utilization of healthcare resources and
services such as our therapeutic
cannabis program and do not allow
medical professionals to expand and
operate within their scope of practice
that being said by supporting a livefree
bill the state of New Hampshire can
leave the unscientific bias
fear-mongering stigma behind and display
the ethical principle of
autonomy ver
verticity non-maleficence and
beneficence and Justice to its citizens
ultimately it would allow for added
economic growth through legal state
sales discouraging out ofate purchases
creating cannabis entrepreneurs and
businesses and allowing young medical
professionals like myself to expand our
careers in New Hampshire or be pushed to
relocate to another neighboring state in
which we can openly practice cannabis
nursing for the benefit of adult use in
medical patients currently many medical
patients as we've heard before travel
outside the state and these are creating
Al offenses as well as increase the risk
for the illicit Market to have ADD in
poly drugs such as fentanyl or
Blues I have found in speaking with
patients at the hospital fellow
Healthcare professionals and local
residents as I also work in the
restaurant industry in conquered that
the illegal status in the state is one
of the many reasons individuals do not
disclose the use to healthcare
professionals this brings on risks when
patients go under anesthesia or other
operations whether it's planned or
emergent and many fear the stigma
associated with speaking with a
healthcare provider to obtain a medical
card by supporting this bill it would
change the stigma associated with
cannabis and allow for adult citizens
again adult citizens to be open truthful
and educated about safe cannabis use
while retaining the promising Financial
gains from the adult youth cannabis
industry and that is all I have to
say thank you very much that was very
informative thank okay I
will close the public hearing on 1639
and we'll see you all again next
Wednesday
afternoon next when the
week here tomorrow no no excuse me
1639 subcommittee will be next
Wednesday